up to the classic
in for a pence in for a shilling thank you for the podcasting hi Minky hello oh EBGM Matt is back my walkthrough walk through Matt show ad yeah um I have birthday next week and that would be so happy if you can do anything special for your upcoming birthday obviously much advertisement oh so crazy you would ask ah all right guys wait okay that goes there we're here I just got some salt is this the salt wait can I put the fishing rod back no way I just stole this guy it's my birthday today thank
you oh my gosh why are there so many doos and everything now well thank you so much for the time
yay happy birthday everybody every birthday every birthday you can't return the rod that's so sad
800 franc fishing rod i know he was so he was like saying everything about this rod somebody birthdays today we just started there's already birthday birthday birthday and me too next week
yeah have you seen my telescopic ultra
You're not asking about a fishing rod, are you?
I...
It must have been that darn cat knocked it into the water!
Which I also...
Wait, I don't have the cat in the blanket anymore.
Okay.
Sorry.
I wanted to give a little bit of a recap.
Because, you know.
So much happened.
Last time.
Welcome back, everybody, to the Mr. of the druids.
So happy to be here.
Hope one day we get a 3D Minto on a gaming stream.
Hopefully one day.
Yes, we're in France now.
France.
And everybody was very adamant that I needed to get salt before I left the screen or else the game would be softlocked.
But we are gamers.
and we avoided Colonel.
We managed to avoid salt locking.
So, yay, yay, yay, yay, yay.
Um, I, I, okay, so this game is about a weird detective and we got this case from another guy that was fired because he thought it was the butcher, but it was not the butcher.
And now we learned that maybe It was an ancient ritual because of some gold and a sickle or something.
Good luck on Druids, thank you!
Don't forget to get peppermintky, it tastes great!
Lowry wasn't fired.
He was fired from the case.
He was taken off the case.
Sorry, that's why I knew he wasn't fired as a police officer.
And, yeah, we also lost our wallet and we maybe poisoned a man.
And now we're in France for some reason.
I'm headed out on a very long road trip tomorrow.
Oh my goodness.
Vanilla, good luck.
I'll probably be watching your 3D live from a tent in rural North Dakota.
It's my first big road trip after health.
of stuff.
Whoa!
Have fun!
Have fun, have fun.
That's been a while, but my birthday was August 4th.
Wow, it was a... Happy belated birthday, RoboCorps.
But yeah, we're here.
We're gonna go check out a castle.
I want to get a lot done today, so let's just get into it.
Run.
Run, Halagin, run.
Run!
So we need to go to How do you pronounce this?
Shlob!
Yes.
How mysterious.
Looks like this used to be a tower.
But it's collapsed.
Used to be a tower, but the way he runs.
He's so tiny.
No, go inside.
Go inside.
Shloss.
Ah.
Thank you.
What's in here?
Something.
Now we can explore.
The music lasted literally two seconds.
That's fine.
Okay.
Is there anything for me to click on?
Nothing.
I can observe.
And that's it?
You're up soon.
Min's next magic trick.
Watch her play this game and make her sanity disappear.
Nothing here.
Oh, that's a castle.
Eh.
Yeah?
Is there anything else?
Around here?
What?
Looks like this used to be a tower, but it's collapsed.
Wait, is this literally all that's it?
Wait, no way.
Why am I here?
Wait.
Why?
oh four months with the members felix thank you as a frenchman i feel insulted i feel you insulted my culture oh no the humanity um sorry you need to get to the cemetery do girl wait this way maybe oh this okay this way run i like the way he like moonwalks kind of
Colombo.
Oh, okay.
We can go down here.
Can we go over here?
Oh, what's this?
A tower.
This castle must have been a real fortress before it collapsed.
Oh, so many towers.
Okay.
Downstairs.
Boss area, but you're too early.
Oh, we're here.
We're here.
What is this?
Okay.
It's not locked, is it?
Locked.
It's locked.
Oh, sorry.
Oh, no.
The gate is locked.
An iron gate.
Locked.
Oh.
Anybody that can get me in?
Find a key.
Oh.
This looks so suspicious.
No, this like little rock on the ground.
Okay.
If I were...
I would be under a rock if I were a key to a place.
I'd be under a rock.
Locked.
Maybe in here now.
That's where they're hiding it.
A ghost!
Oh, it's a cute one.
Meow.
No, I'm actually quite spooky and scary.
Thank you.
Why are they...
music disappear.
Okay.
It's going to be the tiniest thing.
The tiniest little thing.
It's in the tree.
It's not.
It's in the tower.
It's so quiet.
anonymous agony playthrough for the birthday stream or maybe pathologic i think birthday stream will just be a little more chill uh watch out for the droods i'm watching notice you love frumpy don't call the frumpy middle-aged bed
unless you're like wanting to feel better about yourself.
Oh, Minto loves grumpy middle-aged men, so when I inevitably become one, it'll be okay.
I ordered an apple cider at the maid cafe, but as soon as I drank it, it passed out of work without my spare change, Missy.
Ah, Missy, your wallet?
Looks like this used to be a tower, but it's collapsed.
I don't...
No.
Okay, wait.
Okay, let's go back.
Okay, what did we get the salt for?
Everybody said I needed it.
But I also have no...
What is it?
Is it going to, like, erode the lock or some stupid baloney?
Okay, let's try it.
Let's try our items on this.
Locked.
It's locked.
Is this the salt?
That's futile as well.
It's futile.
Worse than that!
Are we going to...
Are we gonna use it for like some food?
It's the one of the dumbest puzzle solutions in the game.
You technically already have the key in your inventory.
How it works just doesn't make sense.
Oh, okay, so it was something in my inventory.
Is it this?
No, better not.
No.
Is it the bone?
I should think about it again.
No.
Is it...
Uh...
I have it?
In my inventory?
Is it...
Is it the blanket?
It won't work like that.
Just go in.
I can't.
The gloves.
That won't get me any further.
Okay.
I have to talk to the captain first.
Nothing I have here.
I feel works.
I thought the salt made sense.
Okay.
Okay,
back to here.
Hello, Capitan.
Capitan.
Help me.
I've just started the game and I'm lost.
Missila, Capitan.
What can I do for you?
Um, I've got a few more questions.
What was our last conversation?
I've got a few more questions concerning our last conversation.
Good morning, Marty.
Good morning, Miles.
me anything you like my boy they're from this is carmore yeah says you're from carmore like he is is that true yes that's right I have pizza today by the way as a youngster I wanted to be a fisherman and used to work on my father's trawler later I went to Naval College to become a captain of the Merchant Navy of France I have a small house at the end of the road just behind Francoise bistro you
used to work for the merchant can i go to his house yes i have been to practically every single port all over the world from new york to zanzibar no way zanzibar i have sailed all known and unknown oceans rivers backwaters lakes and canals i have seen things no other man on earth has ever seen wow exciting yes yes but all that was a long time look at megatron in a few years time I shall retire and begin working on my memoirs he should just climb over the fence we are a man of the law your memoirs that sounds interesting oh yes my boy I've seen a lot you know disasters storm tides elements mysteries really won't you tell me more I have seen ships disappear in the Bermuda Triangle I saw the Prince of Egypt sink I'm I witnessed the accident of the pride of Paris in Cape Town Harbor.
You were in all those places.
Wow.
And that's not all.
I have seen tsunamis 40 meters high and octopuses with 16 tentacles.
What?
I thought octopuses only had 8 tentacles.
Quite, my boy.
Quite.
I have seen things a common land lover.
No offense, my boy.
Cannot even begin to imagine.
No offense.
Octopuses with twice the normal.
number of tentacles I do have the item well that's quite incredible but I still do I kind of want to hear stories though of course my logs are full of them take the story of Nantucket Island for instance I was stranded there for a number of years would you like to hear it is a long story like I said I spent a number of years there some other time maybe I'm sorry years how can you have wait you fast-tracked to poisoning a guy so you missed how against co-workers not helping you wait what thank you thank you Masula Capitan you've been a great help you're welcome my boy oh my gosh I'm glad your plushies finally came I know that there's been a bit of a delay on a lot of the second batch so thank you guys for your patience okay so we go back
okay let's go down okay I didn't try everything in my inventory we'll try more it's locked
evidence bag we're brute forcing it I don't believe it will work like that are you sure?
um cider that doesn't work okay It doesn't work.
The matches.
We light the place on fire.
That's futile as well.
No, just kidding.
Okay, clipboard.
Not a good idea.
Oh, I thought it was a fine idea.
What is this?
That won't help either.
It won't help.
Cider on the gate.
It'll dissolve it because it's so alcoholic.
Looks like that won't work.
No, okay.
This?
That would be stupid.
Oh, rude.
What about you?
I don't believe it will work like that.
Okay, and this.
Oh, the case file!
Oh, right.
No, stink it.
How is anybody supposed to know?
He's supposed to know.
Sorry, guys.
Weeks.
Weeks of playthrough value.
Oh, my God.
Wow.
We.
Okay.
What do we got here?
What a fine, Ooh, Cemetery.
Yes?
A gravestone.
Pretty weather-beaten.
What is special about this one that you chose to look at this one?
There's a hollow in the top.
A gravestone.
Hollow?
Oh, here?
Pretty weather-beaten.
There's a hollow at the top.
Okay.
Do I put some, oh, what is, is that an owl?
Oh, wow.
Wait, so what can I put here?
Maybe the cider.
That won't get me any.
I should think up something else.
Lang.
Uh, this one.
I should think about it.
Not a good idea.
Just kidding.
Uh.
Uh, the salt.
Oh!
Huh?
Oh, wait.
What?
A gravestone.
Pretty weather-beaten.
What did it do?
How beat it?
Minty Minto says wowie.
Why?
Did I say wowie?
Beep, beep.
Thank you so much for the five gifted.
Wait, why did I do that?
There's a holout, a gravestone.
There's a holout.
Yeah, I did it.
Maybe there's another one.
Wait, what do I...
Why did I do that?
Okay, let's go this way.
Or...
Oh, wait, never mind.
This way first.
The way he turned around.
Oh, I wish the music would come back.
I do wish the...
Oh.
Wait, this one too!
Gravestone.
Pretty weather-beaten.
There's a hollow at the top.
Okay.
Do we have to find the correct one?
We're salting our gravestones for dinner.
Oh.
Sake blue.
Dade!
French, French, French and Japanese.
Whoa, little monkey.
It looks like...
Wait, does this one...
Wait, do these also?
Oh!
A gravest as a hollow at the top.
Okay.
This one also?
Gravest as a hollow at the top.
Okay, I gotta go get my salt back.
Okay.
Wait, this place is huge.
Where'd that guy go?
Okay, let's go here.
Who else salt in their grave?
Yeah, I have to be careful with the salt because I will get exercised.
And today I'm feeling lazy.
Let's go get my salt before I do anything else.
Okay.
You probably need to find a medium rare naked it serves this is hockey okay let's grab my grab that thank you very much okay bye-bye
hmm who was that though that guy it looked like ricky martin in a tight black shirt um well wait oh wait let's go this way first
oh my gosh this place is humongous why are there so many graves that What?
A grave...
There's a hollow at the top.
They all have a hollow at the top.
What's your favorite gravestone topping?
Salt!
A grave...
I love salt on a gravestone.
This really makes it nice and easy to lick.
It's like creating your own salt lick, you know?
Okay, so let's go this way.
Salt.
This place is huge.
Huge!
Oh, they all say the same thing!
Oh my gosh!
A great as a Hollywood.
What?
It looks like...
The door's walled up.
It looks like a kid's sandcastle.
If you think that's bad, one point and click gives you pie.
You can eat at any time or give away to...
And many times to others, you actually need to save it until the end of the game to throw it in the Yeti's face.
Replayability.
The door's walled up.
A mausoleum.
I expect the lord of the castle's buried in there.
Wow.
It's gigantic.
Yeah.
A mausoleum is practically a castle itself.
A mausoleum.
Okay, we can go this way.
This place...
Where am I?
Oh, okay.
Okay, so now we have like 50 gravestones that all...
What?
Oh, I see it in the back now.
Okay.
But where did that guy go?
That guy was a real ghost, huh?
the captain knows what to do I do have to talk to the captain okay thank you so much let's go talk to him Mr. Mr. What do I use the song for?
I love the way he runs especially when he has like an objective that is involving like consulting someone because it seems like such like a little kid the way he runs being like I gotta go ask him I gotta go ask captain mr.
mister I got all this salt and all these graves what do I do yay
music mr.
mister what can I do for you so I've got a few more questions I got a few more questions concerning our last conversation right ask me anything you like my boy yes um okay yeah says you're from carmore like my pizza while they talk is that true yes that's right i grew up here as a youngster i wanted to be a fisherman and used to work on my father's trawler later i went to naval college to become a captain of the merchant navy of france i have a small house at the end of the road just behind francois
he doesn't have much to do I wonder which one is not since the fishing industry went down the drain so he's a fisherman is he he used to have three trawlers and five employees but nobody wants French fish anymore we asked this before no to it's nothing oh sorry my bad I
think hold on thank you miss you're a great help you're welcome my boy I think I have to ask about what can I do for you I've got a few more questions concerning our last conversation all right ask me anything you like my boy pierre says you're from carmore like he is so do I ask I think I asked about the Navy maybe I grew up here as a youngster I wanted to be a fisherman and used to work the captain knows nothing later I went to naval college to become a captain of the merchant Navy of France I have a small house at the end of the road just behind Francois Bissro if
you talk to him tell you about the druids and the salt so do I ask what's the line of think okay let's do the merchant Navy then maybe you used to work for the merchant Navy yes I have been to practically every single port all over the world from New York to Zanzibar from Rotterdam to Cape Town I have sailed all known and unknown oceans rivers backwaters lakes and canals I have seen things no other man on earth has ever seen sounds exciting yes but all that was a long time ago i'm gonna okay uh maybe this one we didn't do and now you only captain the ferry from carmore to portsmouth yes that's right is there anything wrong with that don't you like talking to only captain ferries it's an important job people need ferries because it just so happens there's a lot of water between the islands and the continent and somebody has to steer those ferries but i don't suppose a land lover like you would understand that i didn't mean to offend you captain that's monsieur le capitan charles de
neuve to you my boy you'd better get a bit dry behind the ears before you start talking to season sailors got that yes sir i should think so too oops oh well thanks for
welcome oh does he actually give a i can't tell people are giving me so many different what can i do for you things i can't tell if he actually only talks about how do i get to the castle conversation though i've got a few more questions concerning our last conversation but i can't tell if he only talks about the druids in the castle or if he pia says you're from karm yes later Or if he gives a hint about the salt.
Ask about the memoirs.
Okay.
You can probably proceed with the salt in the grave now.
Wait, really?
Wait, but I don't know what to do.
Wait.
Huh?
Do I need salt for...
What?
I think you got one guide.
Oh!
Okay.
hold on keep going what can you do with salt in a bowl lick it
maybe i'm maybe i need like a maybe i need salt all i think about is licking salt
oh let's see let's find a grave that works If any of these work, I can't imagine I have to go put, like, the salt on every single grave, you know what I mean?
So let's try one.
Let's try, okay, let's do this.
All right, let's put the salt on, and then maybe, towel it.
That won't help either.
Okay.
Bone it!
Oh!
Now I have more salt.
There's no point in that.
Huh?
What?
That didn't answer my question.
I love how the game is also so like, if you're stuck, if you're having trouble, just think about your objective.
And me, I'm kind of like, what is it?
They make you feel like you're dumb whenever.
Everything is so obtuse.
You know?
Was there...
Okay, this has to feel like...
I feel like this has to be something.
The door's walled up.
Okay, do you need a salt?
Yeah!
No way.
No way?
Wait, no way as in like, no way this will work.
Looks like that won't work.
Okay.
Things are answering my questions.
question he keeps fading in and out of existence oh we lost him there he is
oh okay the wall that's what i tried no i expect the lord of the doors walled up the doors walled up it didn't work though hold on that doesn't work it doesn't work Maybe the walls.
The walls walled up.
No, no way.
Oh, what?
What?
It seems to have worked.
Oh, we got the amulet.
This must be the amulet.
I found it.
This is what will cause.
Wait, this is what will prevent.
Oh, my gosh.
The druids don't know what salt is.
They've never seasoned their steaks.
What the
hell?
How?
So, now we have the amulet, this will prevent them from doing their ritual that will destroy the world!
And the babies!
Wait, what if that guy in the black shirt, what if Ricky Martin was one of the guys?
Don't worry, Halligan didn't know how that worked either.
Okay, so now we can leave.
I guess.
Who are you?
Run!
Run, Hologan, run!
Huh.
Mysterious man.
So I'm guessing we can, like, leave the port now, right?
Do you believe me if I told you the game gets dumber?
Wait, what?
Druids have seasoned their stakes before there were no survivors.
Ah, I see, I see.
Is there a spammer?
I don't see it on my side.
Oh wait, yes I do.
Please no spam!
Maybe I should stop salting my food so much.
Okay, sorry about that.
I didn't see it.
Okay.
Onwards!
We got the amulet.
Let's go back to maybe our guy.
Oh, um...
Talk to him about- I hope the guy is not dead.
You know?
At least it was a nice spammer.
They were nice, yeah.
Saying I was, saying I was cute.
Monsieur Le Capitan.
What can I do for you?
When are you leaving?
When are you leaving for Portsmouth?
In two hours.
Are you coming?
Yes.
Then come aboard.
Oh, oh, oh.
Wow, my room.
I have to sit on board for two hours.
Wow, they give me so close.
I don't think I need to change my clothes just yet.
Clothes and stuff.
I don't...
That's my hold all.
A what?
It's too early to pack.
We won't be arriving yet.
A hold all?
That's my hold all.
Wow, that's what British people call a bag.
My spare suit.
Just in case.
Mm-hmm.
Okay.
Clothes and stuff.
I'm going to call, I'm going to say that to Limeu next time and be like, Oh, Limeu, today I went to the department store and I got Hodo.
I'm Carl McRug-Angie.
Neal-Minky voice make happy.
Hello.
That's the sea out there.
No kidding.
The sea.
what do we take a nap i'm not tired just kidding a bunk rather spartan wow though wait how long of a ride is it that we get a whole room hold on i think i'd better leave the amulet in the cabin i don't lose it otherwise no or it might be stolen i think it might be stolen on the ship in the room you went all the way to france and all you did was steal a fishing rod and blew up a castle with salt maybe in here this is like the least no Hmm.
It's empty.
Okay.
Don't put it in there, though.
You wouldn't be so dumb.
Okay, good.
Well, put it in my spare coat pocket.
Oh, whoops.
Wrong button.
I don't want that.
Just kidding.
I can't do that.
That won't help either.
No, not a chance.
Not a good idea.
Oh, wait.
I can't see any connection there.
Okay.
Hmm.
Let's hide it under my pillow.
for the druid fairy.
Wait.
It won't work like that.
Okay, I thought it was about to work.
Pizza.
What part of England is the accent from Minto?
Truffle bottom.
Okay, we could throw it out the window.
Hmm.
Nothing's happening.
Okay.
Uh...
Where can I hold...
Where can I hide this?
Uh, in the bed?
It won't work like that.
No, in my pocket then.
There it goes, in the pocket.
Hide it in the pocket.
What?
Hmm.
Back in here?
That doesn't work.
Really?
What about my shoes?
No?
I should think up something else.
time to pixel hunt there's no point in that oh my goodness i think i tried everything in here let me just double check this the clothes and stuff i don't want that i don't want that won't get me any further okay the duffel bag it's not that it's not the duffel bag not a good idea that's futile as well think first brent oh my god no way it won't work like that won't get me in no way no way uh-huh if i were a halogen and i'm trying to hide an amulet from an evil cult where would i hide it in the room where would i hide it in the room open the drawer first i don't think it works like that hmm it's empty yeah see he closes it And then it won't let me select it again with the amulet.
If I were a guy, if I were a peculiar man who had very...
A light, no?
Under the bed?
It won't work like that.
Top right vent, it doesn't...
No, wait, no.
That won't help either.
Okay, okay.
Off-colored vent panel.
Nope, it was not that...
Oh!
I'd rather think about it again.
What?
But that feels like it...
Then why...
Let me...
Eh?
You'll have to open it first.
Ah!
Sorry, I've been really sneezing today.
There we go!
Ah!
I see I see okay yeah perfect hiding place for the amulet no one will find it there right I think I'll go and get some fresh air I'm feeling a bit breezy you cut him
off God what's been going on here someone's broken into my cabin and searched through all my things oh who would have thought this would happen No, not like that.
What's this?
I think they're fur needles.
Fur needles.
Whoever did this made a thorough job of it.
My bed!
Whoever did this made...
Whoever did this made a thorough job of it.
You think they made a thorough job of it, you guys?
No!
My suit!
Whoever did this made a thorough job.
Whoever did this...
Whoever did this made a thorough job of it.
Okay, okay.
The amulet.
Where's the amulet?
It's been stolen.
I don't believe it.
I cannot believe it.
Last it.
The thief must still be on board.
But we're pulling into the harbor.
I'll never catch him now.
Walks away with no sense of urgency at all.
Uh-oh.
On the...
let's go talk to this guy and see maybe is he still alive maybe please be alive Blake
I sound extra cute today hello mr.
Blake I'm back and did you find the amulet that's a long story mr.
it's pretty bad we'll go on then I can't wait to hear what happened I found the amulet it was walled up in the Lord's William really it really does exist then and you've got it show me well I did have it but it was stolen from me stolen how did that happen no idea I hid it in my cabin during the crossing someone broke in and rummaged through all my luggage was anything else missing no not a thing someone must have been following you I didn't notice anyone.
Who could have known I'd be looking for an amulet and a God-forsaken dump.
Certain people may be taking a great interest in your investigations, Mr. Holligan.
Do not underestimate the power of the druids.
Oh,
oh, I don't know.
Perhaps it was just a case of ordinary petty theft.
I haven't met anyone who looks like a druid so far.
Are you saying the druids stole the amulet?
That's absurd.
Well, I really haven't met anyone, though.
a druid.
I haven't met anyone who looked like a druid so far.
No, no, Mr. Halligan.
You won't recognize the inheritors by their cloaks and sickles.
They're people, just like you and me.
They could be powerful industrialists, high-ranking politicians or influential military men, people in key positions of society.
What can I do then?
I can't possibly check up on the entire upper class of British society, looking for a couple of druids.
No.
But it may be worth your while to keep an eye on groups of neo Druids.
If anyone tries to justify their claims to the Druids' inheritance, they will.
Neo... The Matrix Druids?
Neo Druids?
What are they?
There are a number of groups around claiming to be the Druids' rival successors.
They're organized in orders, like Templars or Freemasons.
Tell me more.
Tell me more about these Neo Druids.
Like I said, the Neo Druids try to their lives according to ancient druid ideals.
Some of them do a lot of charitable work as well.
But there are some really dubious associations going around, combining the druid's customs with occult rites.
Rumors say that they're such a sect at large, somewhere in London.
In London?
In London, you said.
Do you know where I might find these people?
I have no idea.
All I know is that the only people who know anything about the Order refer to it as The circle.
The circle.
Oh, okay.
Thank you.
Thank you, Mr. Blake.
I'll see what I can make of it.
If you have any more questions, don't hesitate to call on me.
Anytime you like.
Thank you.
Oh.
Oh, wiggles.
Oh, one more thing, Mr. Blake.
Oh my gosh.
Uh-oh.
This means Mr. Blake is the criminal.
One more thing, Mr. Blake.
Yes.
I get the impression this business could get pretty dangerous from now on.
likely mr.
Halligan it may be safer for both of us if we let someone else in on the matter please call Melanie Turner in Oxford and tell her the whole story make sure she learns everything you've told me she works at the Anthropological Museum her numbers in the phone book and tell her I'll get in touch with her myself as soon as possible kind of crazy would you do that for me of course mr.
Halligan yeah her numbers you can find it numbers in the phone book no
biggie is my favorite song in the whole game so far i'm expecting to see ricky martin and like out of the corner of our eye and every scene now
um okay we probably don't need to go talking to her if he's calling her uh maybe we go to the scotland yard and we researched the circle.
Halligan?
Into my office at once.
Uh-oh.
That doesn't sound good.
What did I do?
Wait, what did I do?
Uh-oh.
Halligan, come on in.
I suppose we should be glad that you drop in now and then.
What's the matter, Chief?
I'm doing my job.
You know, Halligan, I was just asking myself what you've been doing.
I've been investigating, Chief.
Well, have you?
And do you know what I've been doing I've been dismissing loads of press people worried citizens and politicians from my office the phone hasn't stopped ringing since this morning the mayor's been to my office and I haven't seen much of you when do you expect to come up with results I'm getting there chief I'm getting there chief but it takes time takes time takes time will I ever get to hear anything else from a detective where the heck have you been Halligan you're get a report at the end of the week the end of the week why not at the end of the month or the end of the year I want the results on my desk tomorrow morning Halligan and now I want to know where you've been all this time we I mean sorry sorry I just got back from France and I'm like you know like still in French Britain we you'll find out when you read the report I'm going to write don't be impertinent detective as your chief I'm entitled to ask you about the results of investigations and your proceedings whenever I like.
Yes, Chief, of course.
That sounds better.
Otherwise, I could have you write a report about every single step of your proceedings, and I think you know that.
Very well, then.
I was visiting an expert on druids.
You wrote what?
Alligan, have you lost your marbles?
You're not supposed to be indulging in your hobbies.
You're supposed to be solving the skeleton murders.
Is that all?
Oh, my hobbies!
Wow, I wish I could be a druid.
Is that all, Chief?
No, that is not all.
One of the phone calls this morning was from the 4th District in Oxford.
Another murder?
And?
A beggar has been to see them.
He claimed that somebody had first put him to sleep and then robbed him.
Wait.
And do you know who that person was?
Do I have consequences for my actions?
A man who calls himself Detective Halligan.
Our colleagues looked into the central personal database and guess what?
They found a man by the name of Detective Halligan.
for my department I just gave him what he asked for the
the beggar must be mistaken chief the beggar must be mistaken it's a mix-up it's a mix-up I hope so if these accusations turn out to be true you can spend the rest of your professional life washing police cars um I I what did you when did you receive when did you received the phone call from our colleagues oh less than half an hour ago have you any idea how embarrassed i was about the affair the colleague i talked to said that the beggar still had some of the substance he'd been knocked out with medical alcohol with apple juice haligan please tell me you didn't do it i had nothing to do with it chief honestly well i hope your benefit he says honestly you to start looking into the case at hand well chief you know i asked everybody in office to help me find my wallet and you know what nobody agreed so i had to do what i had to do
you know i could be considered the beggar because i was begging for help and nobody wanted to help me it was just a prank okay chief i read you indeed Excellent, detective.
Then get out and do your job.
I've been!
If I should hear that you are conducting your investigations in any dubious or illegal way, I'll take you off the case immediately.
Understood, Chief.
Yes, Chief.
You think he is mad at me?
I didn't think that that would happen.
Let's go talk to the guy that supplied me with the stuff.
Are we the baddies?
No.
Um, hey you!
Wait, what are you working on over there?
What is this stink?
Wait, what is that?
Was that there before?
Wait, what- There's nothing I can do with this.
What is that?
I don't remember seeing that before.
Okay, anyway.
Hello.
Hey, Halligan.
How'd you get on with Miss Turner?
Are you gonna see her again?
You could say that.
What?
really congratulations mate thank you thank you and could she help you with the bones I think so I'm on a new trail I see sounds mysterious thank you it is Chris it is perhaps I'll tell you when I find out more all right Hannigan good luck anyway thanks thank you thank you is Hannigan a sissy okay she um I don't think Let's do this for fun times.
Meet when I lie.
Okay, I saw someone say to read a walkthrough.
Oh wait, we have a message though.
Brent?
Hello.
Mom?
Is that you?
Or is it the queen?
It's your mother.
know I hate these modern talking machines I haven't heard anything from you for months now Brent is that any way to treat your mother a month aren't any celebrating her 75th definition of high functioning cycle we have both been invited you will come won't you rent and please wear something smart smart give me a favor oh god that's all i need there was another one though next hello sir this is uh al's pizza palace your account from last quarter has not yet been paid it amounts to 275 pounds Please see to it within the next few days.
Otherwise, we will have to stop serving you.
275?
Wow, that's my personal record.
Guy!
Hello, Mr. Halligan.
This is Melanie Turner speaking.
I was wondering why I hadn't heard from you, but Mr. Blake just called and told me everything.
Oh, my God, I'm crying.
I'm out and about quite a lot at the moment, and you may have difficulties trying to get me on the phone.
But if you need me, just leave a message.
Okay.
See you later.
Let me give you some good advice, Detective Halligan.
Don't interfere with our affairs.
It wouldn't be very healthy.
What?
What was that?
No way!
That's about 485 pounds today.
What?
Uh-oh, we got a call from the Druids!
Do you see why this gave us that?
the best alligan this is miller damn it where are you where are you i have to speak to this damn answering machine if i want to get hold of you where are you if by any chance you happen to turn up in this department i want to see you in my office okay we have one more miller speaking i've had enough you better come to my office as soon as possible six hundred and ninety three dollars usd i'm glad i've got that behind me oh my god okay let's see save real quick while I remember.
Minto, we'll just do Minto 5.
Okay.
Resume.
Can you guys tell how like messed up my screen is without like the window looks?
Oh gosh.
I hope the Druids win.
Yeah.
Okay.
So, do we need to like call?
I never use the receiver.
That thing is just too heavy.
Using the loudspeaker is much more comfortable.
Do we need to like call, what's her name?
Uh...
Melanie, maybe, but I don't know her phone number.
Chief Inspector Miller will get this.
The results of the investigation in my last case.
Conclusion?
The offender could not be determined.
Oh, no.
My writing desk.
I am definitely the only one who can make head or tail of it.
Can we?
Yeah, can we?
Unfortunately, there's no pizza in there anymore.
Al's Pizza Palace makes the best pizza in the whole of London.
Al's pizza palace makes the best pizza in the whole of London.
Al's pizza palace makes the best pizza in the whole world.
God, why does he call it that?
Is that a British thing?
Al's pizza palace makes the best pizza in the whole of London.
Oh, sorry, whole of London.
I was getting way ahead of myself.
My writing desk.
Oh, it's German.
Oh, okay, okay.
Oh, okay.
gosh oh okay um maybe maybe we go see melanie maybe you can buy soft drinks for high prices here high prices why is this not an office german i feel like i asked that last time hello janet it's me again it's me again i can see that He was the only ghostmate that eats about 30 pounds of pizza,
everyone.
Uh, my database inquiry.
What about my database inquiry now?
I don't like to repeat myself, Brent.
Have you not been listening?
Yes, of course I have.
Well, then you know it all, don't you?
Sure.
In that case, see you later, Brent.
Oh, okay.
Good.
See you later, then.
Take your time, Brent.
Thank you.
Yeah, she does hate me.
Okay.
Um.
Flowery?
You in here?
Oh, yeah.
Can I talk to you?
It's my thumbnail.
It's so good.
What is it this time, Halligan?
Have you ever heard of an organization called the Surveillance?
Have you ever heard of an organization called The Circle?
The Circle?
Is that somehow connected to the crop circles?
Okay, forget it, Larry.
She's got her cat-haired, covered scarf back.
I'd like to know how you managed to get a date with Janet.
I'd really like to know how a Braggard like you managed to get a date with Janet.
Well, you know what, Halligan?
Women do like a winner, don't they?
Little Janet is no exception.
We went to the palace yesterday.
What was showing?
The new Schwarzenegger film.
You know how to handle women, don't you?
Of course.
Janet said she found it disgusting, but I know for a fact that she was very keen on it.
Women are like that.
Do you understand?
Why should a woman like her find your boring story so entertaining?
Well, I would have thought that Janet had more sense.
Women like winners, minto.
I definitely read that as weeners.
I was like, how's that?
Okay.
I love a good hot dog.
Um, yeah, I thought she had more sense.
Well, I would have thought that Janet had more sense.
Oh, actually, I think she's got very good sense.
That's why she always refuses to let you take her out somewhere.
She prefers to go out with a man who doesn't dress in rags, dragged out of rubbish bins, or eat the same pizza every day.
Would you say that?
The facts speak for themselves, Halligan.
You eat pizza in your office, and I go to the cinema with you.
Janet that's the way things work oh I'm sorry old boy dang what
amazes me is why a woman like her should find your boring stories about cars sports and action films so entertaining Halligan I'm sure you didn't come to tell why is his dialogue so different from the subtitles could I use your phone could I just use your phone haven't you got your own telephone Halligan I just wanted to try something I just wanted to try something and what if I might ask try to get a dialing tone that's right wait what are we where are we going with this that's right the chief can explain it to you for certain have fun you're a really nice you're a really nice person Lowry I do my best okay bye Okay,
I'll talk to you later, Lowry.
He doesn't even say bye to me.
Wait, but I want to know about the phone.
The phone.
Wait, where can I find Detective Stryker?
Who is that?
Where can I find Detective Stryker?
Stryker?
On holiday.
Why?
He still owes me money.
Okay, I heard he was suspended.
Who is this guy?
Okay.
Maybe he knows more about the organization called the Circle.
Oh, you're still going on about that, are you?
Well, if you want to hear my opinion, Halligan, those strange crop circles were drawn in the fields by a pensioner.
By the way, what's that got to do with the skeleton murders?
Dear God, Lowry, just tell me where I can find Stryker.
He could tell me in an envelope.
about the skeleton murders.
Halligan, I coordinated the case.
Striker was my right hand.
You won't get anything new out of him.
Could I use your phone?
Could I just use your phone?
Haven't you got your own telephone, Halligan?
I wanted to...
Oh, there's something not quite right with it.
Yes, but there's something not quite right with it.
No dialing tone.
Is that it?
What's your extension?
Tell me, Lowry.
196.
You know that.
Yes, right.
I just forgotten it.
don't phone you so very often.
Yeah, and that's the way I like it, Halligan.
Don't you dare start ringing me up and getting on my nerves.
One nine six, everybody.
That's his codec.
How do you know that?
Someone in accounts has had a look at the department's telephone bills, Halligan, and you're the record holder by a very, very wide margin.
Wait, what?
Your phone will only work internally from now on.
Janet told me that when we went to the cinema.
Where do you keep calling to?
Anyway, the Caribbean.
I don't think that's got anything to do with you, Lowry.
Oh, yes, okay, of course, sure.
It's none of my business.
But if you think that you can make your phone calls from here, you're dead wrong.
I think we might be a terrible, like, a terrible cop.
What is happening?
Wait, what?
Clearly not your mom.
Wait.
Tell me, Lowry, what's your extension?
196, you know that.
Yes, right.
Okay.
I'll talk to you later.
Bye.
Wait.
Oh.
Halligan.
Yes.
Might I ask you what you think you're doing?
I need Scissors 61.
I don't know what you mean, Steve.
You don't know what I mean?
You're trying to steal a pair of scissors from right under my nose, but you haven't got a clue what I'm talking about.
Is that it?
I don't need your scissors for very long.
Now, listen, Lowry, I really don't need your scissors for very long.
I said, forget it.
All right, then, keep them.
Why can we take the scissors?
Wait, I was just trying to leave.
Oh, there we go.
It's at the bottom.
Okay.
What's wrong with this guy?
Wait, now 196.
Okay, 196.
196.
Scotland Yard, Detective Lowry.
Hello?
I never use the receiver.
Oh.
That thing is just too heavy.
Using the loudspeaker is much more comfortable.
What do you mean heavy?
One, nine, six.
Scotland Yard, Detective Lowry.
Hello?
Who's speaking?
one nine six low level super villain ah pick up pick up Lowry okay I really don't know where to go from here okay actually let's go to maybe our lady friend who is not interested in us at all but we are shooting our shot I suppose she did say she was busy so I don't know if she'll actually be here.
Get Lowry fired so you could steal his scissors.
I'm not kidding.
Wait, what?
Oh, I can't go in.
Did I knock?
No, okay.
Locked.
Wait, what?
Wait, is this the truth?
Did you call her?
I don't know her number.
Oh, I guess we could call here.
but yeah uh try guys try not to like backseat so hard like i know that this game is a little obtuse but i do want to try things without before like everybody starts like spamming the next steps and all that oh
i can't call her unless unless i memorized her number oh wait i have no money i can't hear any dialing yeah i have no more money i forgot
see is that guy still here why is he sometimes like stop running hi hello haven't seen you for a while you you get lost you crook you nick all my pennies me last 60 pence it's bad enough i get robbed and the police do nothing about it now you coppers are nicking the stuff yourselves Let's say it was business.
I really needed money for the phone.
And you got my lovely homemade schnapps in return.
Gorgeous schnapps.
That stuff wipe me out straight.
I want nothing to do with you, mate.
Get lost.
Come on.
Don't be like that.
You again.
You better leave me alone.
Yeah, I think he's going to stab me.
You again.
You better leave me alone.
I think he might.
I think he hates me.
I think everybody hates me in this game.
All right, let's...
Okay, well, I guess we're going to get...
him fired how we do that is um wait so we need the scissors for what justified absolutely you know Miller speaking okay I've had enough oh wait you better come to my office as soon as possible wait did you get that did oh wait what if I play this while I'm on the phone.
Oh, wait, hold on.
I just accidentally exited out of my capture.
One second.
Oh, wait.
Maybe I'm a genius.
All right.
So, 196.
And then, which one was more angry?
Alligan?
Oh, no, not that one.
This is Miller.
Damn it, where are you?
Do I have to speak to this damned answering machine if I want to get hold of you?
Okay, it's the next one.
any chance you okay next one this one okay speaker one nine six Scotland yard detective Lowry play Miller speaking I've had enough you better come to my office as soon as possible did you get that oh of course sir I'm coming I'm on my way ha ha okay now we go get his scissors for unknown purpose
okay take them awesome leave and run back to my room and save okay now I have these and I don't know what I need them for I just have learned that I need them Is that all you can take for...
Let's see if he's back in there.
Oh!
Hello.
Halligan, where are my scissors?
I've no idea.
I thought they were on your desk just a minute ago.
Don't lie to me, Halligan.
I know you've got them.
And what was that business with the chief all about?
I really don't know what you're talking about.
Steve.
Let me make myself clear.
I hate that kind of thing, Halligan.
I've had quite enough trouble with the chief for one day.
thank you now tell me what it is you want nothing really then get out you again I don't want to see you here again today okay okay you sound so sad okay bye why are we like this hold on me when I lie me when I lie oh things coming up Halligan do
we talk to you I have this I'm trying to think of what the scissors what was something something I'm chief what is it now Halligan why are you yelling at me couldn't you think again about couldn't you think again about the security regulations are you deaf I said no now get out okay okay I'm going sorry sir sorry sir so sorry so sorry okay hold on um let's see we need to learn about the circle is there anywhere outside that we could go to
uh use the scissors to save the queen
We tried the museum.
Well, we didn't have the scissors then, but...
Check all the inventory items.
Maybe we can combine it with something.
That's futile as well.
Just kidding.
Of course.
It can't.
The green scarf.
It's Janet's.
Hmm.
We know?
Scissors are sacred.
about the case.
The papers with the clipboard.
Oh, let's try it.
That doesn't work.
There's no point.
A sheet of carbon paper.
Very useful when dealing with bureaucrats.
Oh!
That worked!
I should think about it again.
That's a form for stationary procurement.
Without that, you don't get anything at Scotland Yard.
Stationary procurement?
What?
A sheet of carbon paper.
Very useful when dealing with bureaucrats.
Very useful.
A sheet of carbon paper.
I don't want that.
Okay.
Very useful when dealing with bureaucrats.
Please draw a veto sitting on the copying.
You need a famous purple stuffed worm.
Okay, well...
We...
What about the salt?
We use the salt to blow up the castle or the mausoleum.
Okay, help!
Help!
Head up in me!
I don't know what to do next.
I have no idea.
No elf vine, then I'll look it up myself.
Mystery.
Of the druids.
Walk through.
We're trying to...
Well, we didn't get him fired.
Hmm.
Use the carbon paper to trick a signature.
I think all three papers did go, no?
But it won't let me...
That's a...
A sheet of cart, of course.
It won't let me like...
Okay, hold on.
Without that, you don't get anything at Scotland Yard.
That's...
What we can do...
Okay, hold on.
Okay, we can't use it unless...
Maybe I have to be closer to him.
Here we go.
I don't need a signature for obtaining materials.
I need one for obtaining information.
That won't help either.
So I need the sign- wait, why didn't I get the- they would have surprised me if it had worked like that.
Wait, why don't I have the thing for obtaining materials?
Wait.
Back here.
Okay.
Which is which?
We got the carbon paper.
Wait, but...
So I need to forge the signature, but like, what's the order?
I already took them all.
I already took them earlier.
And now they're on here.
That's a form for stationary procurement.
Without that, you don't get anything at Scotland Yard.
Talk to Janet.
We could try.
already talked to her though how does carbon paperwork i actually don't know hello janet no i don't think this is it it's the same combo anyway it's soaked through from the room the printer oh well we did ask what's his name about how the printer worked why should i copy that i can get loads of them from janet okay you're right this this also we don't why should i copy that
the order is clipboard carbon paper in both forms together but i did that a clipboard a sheet of carbon paper that's a form for stationary procurement without that you don't get anything at scotland yard you need to put the regular paper in something hard i did the i did oh this is it oh my gosh i didn't realize it moved in my inventory oh that's why okay That's what was confusing me so much,
you guys.
I was like, what's happening?
Okay, there we go.
Okay, that's...
Because I was like, oh, it's on the clipboard already.
That's why I was so confused!
Okay, we're fine now.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Mr. Mr. I have a form for you to sign.
The carbon paper's still sticking out.
Oh.
The chief is bound to notice that.
Okay.
use the scissors right in front of him okay here you go chief I've got an 88 m9 order form for stationary here for stationary you need new stationary again Halligan you'll lead this department to financial ruin someday do you know that yes sir no I mean no sir it's nothing extravagant I could do with a new pencil sharpener that's all when will you learn to take better care of your things If they hate him so much,
they should fire him.
Every month the accounts department gives me a hard time because of the deficit.
Our budget for office costs is limited.
I know, Chief, but I'm not able to work without a minimum of stationary.
Here, I've prepared this for you.
You just need to sign it.
Okay then, okay, give it to me.
Thank you, sir.
But that's the last time.
Do you understand?
You'll have to buy the next sharpener from your own money.
Yes, sir.
Anything else, detective?
Nope, that was it.
No, that was it.
That's good.
You know the way out, don't you, detective?
Of course, chief.
Oh my goodness, everybody's so rude.
Okay, yay, we got a signature!
Now we can use the database to finally learn about the circle.
The circle of London.
Oh, is she okay?
Oh, I thought she was crying.
Hello, Janet.
Oh.
Wait, I think I need to give the thing to her.
Here you go.
It's me again, Janet.
Hello, Brent.
How's your case going?
Have you got any further yet?
Um.
Did you miss me?
Well, it was nice and quiet without you, Halligan.
Lowry was in real trouble with the chief.
But apart from that, heavenly peace.
Lowry's had bother with the chief?
Whoa, what did happen?
Lowry's had a bother with the chief.
What happened?
I don't know exactly.
It was strange.
The chief didn't want to see Lowry for a whole day.
But Lowry still came into his office because he thought that the chief had called him.
I don't know what was going on there.
Well, Brent, what do you need?
I need information about a group.
I'm looking for information about a group called the Circle.
The Circle.
Just a sec.
It won't take a moment.
Oh, it won't take a moment.
Will it be longer or shorter?
Yes, we've got something in the database about them.
Let me see.
The Circle of London.
An order of Neo-Druits.
Their head office is in London.
The head of the group is called Lord Sinclair.
Lord Sinclair.
Do you know anyone with a criminal record?
Do we know about anyone with a criminal record within the group?
Just give me a second, Brent.
Wait, why did I say Wyatt?
No, you're fine.
Somebody once filed a complaint against Lord Sinclair.
I was doing the whole like, enjoy your food.
You too.
Is that all?
Ah!
No, hang on.
Some months ago, a gardener was killed on Sinclair's estate.
And the murderer was never found.
Oh my god.
After the murder, Lord Sinclair and his order were under surveillance some time but there was nothing conspicuous to be found oh that's interesting anything else well sinclair was fined once wait so this guy has a record no nothing else wow that's a lot could you print that out for me could you please print that out for me of course would you mind telling me what these neo druids have to do with your case is this one of your usual mad ideas I don't think so.
I don't think so.
I'll have a closer look at these people anyway.
Well then, happy hunting.
Unless she gave it to me.
Thanks, Jen.
Good.
Thanks a lot, Janet.
I have to go.
Okay, Brent.
See you later.
Uh, is this it?
This is not it.
Where's the thing that she gave me?
Hello, Janet.
Wait, did she give me the address?
Calligan, what's up?
A ss.
Oh, could you print the data once again?
more could you print out the data once more well you've already got one copy that's enough okay okay thank you anyway Janet don't mention it Brent maybe I need a copy of it maybe I can make my own copy not sure why I would need that but we'll see oh is this it it won't work like that ah sorry I was just trying to lift it up.
The printer in the room with her.
Oh, I see, I see.
Oh, it printed there and there.
Oh, I thought it was, I thought it was, like, going to print and then she hands it to me.
Wait, where's the printer?
Oh, there it is.
Oh, I never noticed it.
That's the printout of the database information on the circle.
Lord Sinclair's address is on it as well.
Oh, okay.
234 Winchester Street.
We got it.
Do I want to make another copy?
I don't know why.
Let's see.
I don't know why I would need one, but just in case, because this game is nonsensical.
Interesting.
We can make another copy.
Okay.
Now I have two copies.
Just for whatever I want?
Okay, let's go.
234 Winchester Street.
More.
Wait.
None of these are that address.
Oh, just kidding.
I should leave a message for Ms. Turner.
I don't know why I didn't read that at all.
Oh, leave a message for Ms. Turner.
Here?
I don't have her number, though.
The third one for good luck.
Miss?
Miller speaking.
We don't have any new ones, right?
No, okay.
Uh, how am I supposed to call her?
Oh, yeah, my phone doesn't work.
You're right.
Okay, Lowry, please.
Lowry.
Lowry, please.
Wait, do we have to do it again?
Nowry, can I use your fallen?
Oh, that's not what I meant to do.
Nowry, can I please, please?
You again?
I don't want to see you here again today, Halligan.
Okay.
Okay, we're going to try the thing we just did.
196.
I've already got the scissors.
Oh.
And Lowry has already had enough fun with the boss.
How do I leave a message for her?
Oh, wait.
Maybe this guy, he will be able to.
Because he knows the professor.
I know you can hear the hurt in his voice when he's just like, I don't want to see you again.
Come on.
Are you alright, Halligan?
How are you getting on?
Yeah.
Everything's fine.
Thanks.
Wait, what?
No.
Are you alright, Halligan?
Yeah.
It won't let me...
Well, okay, let's...
It wouldn't let me go to the St. Clair place, but maybe we can go to the museum.
Since he was saying he wants to leave a message, so...
Oh, we could probably put the file through the...
The door.
Like the little mail slot, you know?
Here.
There you go, ma'am.
Okay.
That should be enough for Ms. Turner to find me in case something happens to me.
Yes.
There's a little rut.
I know it's so funny.
He's such a goofy guy.
Okay.
Now we can go to Lord Sinclair.
Not a bad little villa.
This Sinclair doesn't seem to be a poor man.
Not at all.
Not a bad little villa.
This Sinclair doesn't seem to be a poor man.
Wait, what's over here?
Oh, oh, oh, wait, wait, let's let's try the front door first.
Ping pong.
Those dogs?
Yes, who's there?
Is that Lord Sinclair?
No, sir.
I'm sorry.
I am his lordship's butler.
Wait, save?
Should I get out of this first?
Wait, should I save first before I do this?
Hold on.
Oh, wait.
Let's save here.
My bad.
just in case I don't want to like soft lock out of a conversation okay there we go I'm the butler yes who's there is that Lord Sinclair no sir I'm sorry I am his lordship's butler the butler mmm Scotland yard Scotland yard please open the door I regret that his lordship does not receive beggars salesmen and police officers as a matter of principle sir besides Lord Sinclair is not at home at present in the name of the law open the door oh really no beggars and police officers right in the name of the law open the door otherwise I'll kick it down mr.
excuse me what was your name wait no don't say it detective Halligan from Scotland young they're gonna Oh gosh.
Am I correct in assuming that you do not possess a search warrant?
Well...
Then I would like to...
Yeah, say Lowry!
Say Lowry!
Violent and unauthorized intrusion onto the estate can be prosecuted.
I'll be back.
If that's the way you want it, alright then.
You can be sure of that.
Of course, sir.
Oh no!
Why'd you say her name?
Have a nice day.
Why'd you say it?
Oh, oh, wait, it's that!
This river is really huge.
Such a palace.
Ricky Martin.
I need one person.
This man is tall.
Hello.
today isn't it yeah the weather is great just right for a walk yes that's what i thought i didn't want to sit in the office any longer on such a wonderful autumn day yes i know what you mean what kind of job do you do then me oh i work with the agricultural office administration of public areas that kind of thing you know really is there something wrong with lord sinclair's I'm here on a private visit.
I just wanted to get some fresh air.
Oh yeah, I'm just like, trust, I'm just walking around this guy's property.
Always says his day before committing his crimes.
Yeah, professional pride.
Uh, you work for him?
Well, yeah, what are you doing?
What are you doing at the moment?
I have to cut the hedges.
They grew rampantly this summer.
Lord Sinclair doesn't want them to project over the paths where they could be in the way of walkers.
He's a conscientious person.
Yeah, thank you.
Oh, yes, absolutely.
He leads a very secluded life here, and he's always conscious of not doing anything that could annoy other people.
I see.
I.
You may need...
Wait.
What could annoy people out here?
Wait, didn't he get that complaint, though?
He has annoyed people.
What could annoy people out here?
Well, somebody could feel disturbed by disorderly hedges, for example, or somebody could get hurt.
There would be a complaint or a caution or something like that.
Oh my gosh, no.
Not an HOA.
He doesn't like things like that.
He wants everything done in a way that guarantees that he won't be bothered.
Okay.
You mean he wants to be left in peace?
Yes, you could say that.
Even I don't see him very often.
often travels with a gentleman from his club.
Oh, club.
What's Lord Sinclair's profession?
You mean, does he work?
Or you don't have to work when you're that rich.
I think he plays the stock market.
Oh.
And sometimes his bodyguards talk about new deliveries.
People.
Lord Sinclair is certainly involved in some sort of import-export business.
They're probably sacrifices.
I don't think that he needs the money.
is he's just a hobby of his or something like that yeah flesh so he has bodyguards so he has bodyguards of course a man in his position needs them and i can tell you you wouldn't fool around with them two former officers from the foreign legion you know what kind of people they are i'm always very careful with them anyway i try to keep out of their way is this lordship afraid of something i think he's just a very careful man Does he travel often?
Does he travel often?
Is he at home right now?
Yes, he is at home at the moment.
He has some visitors.
I think he and his friends are planning a little party.
They're going to have dinner together tonight.
They have done that quite often recently.
The Butler lie.
This guy is just yapping.
Hasn't he got employees who arranged these things for him?
Oh, sure.
But his lordship is very choosy regarding those dinners.
He insists on cooking everything himself and even buys the ingredients.
He's a really passionate cook.
He procures the ingredients through nefarious means?
If I was rich, I'd have all my meals served in bed.
So would I.
You can bet your life on that.
But really rich people have their own ideas about all that.
Lord Sinclair always cooks meals himself.
He buys them.
He even locks the kitchen door.
He probably doesn't want other people to know the recipes he uses.
Yeah, because the ingredients are paper!
Are there going to be many guests?
Well, Lord Sinclair told me that he expects the four gentlemen from his club.
And as usual, a guest of honor.
Really?
This guy is spilling all the secrets.
It's a good thing he's not a villain.
He would tell all his entire plan.
Lord Sinclair always says that the guest of honor is the main person of a successful dinner.
hospitable.
His guests are very important to him.
I see.
Well, I have to go.
I have to go.
Duty calls.
It's like the family from the Walking Dead.
Exactly!
Have a good day.
Oh.
You can get back to work.
Oh!
Oh, so good.
What's on the other side?
Maybe we can eavesdrop.
Ricky Martin.
I don't know any other Ricky Martin.
song other than live in Lavinia Loka but I think that's probably most people too know what's here a fence it's uh wait I can use the scissors some of the wires are too thick for these little scissors dang it I see oh my gloves I can't see any connection there you hold the gloves or you hold this the wires with the He'll rip it apart.
Why won't it say anything, though?
He doesn't say, like, oh, what a peculiar fence.
No, he has no commentary.
Hmm.
What if I say I'm the guest of honor?
Oh, wait.
Hold on.
Let's save.
Uh.
Sit.
Oh, here.
I'll just do Pinto 7.
Hello, it's me and the guest of honor!
Yes, the ghost of honor.
That is me.
Yes, who is it?
It's me again.
Open the door.
Sir, I don't think that it makes sense to repeat our unpleasant conversation.
Now you listen to me, my friend.
You will now immediately...
I don't mean to interrupt you, sir, but if you don't mind, I will ignore your ringing from now on.
Have a nice day, sir.
Why did we say that?
After all this information, we were just fed.
Why didn't we say, oh, yes, it's me, the guest of honor?
It's locked.
Like, why would we...
Why would we be like, oh, yeah.
It's me again.
What if he will hear...
Ignore me this time.
Locked.
Oh, he did ignore me!
We have to break an entry.
Let's see.
With this.
That won't get me any further.
Light it on fire.
It won't work.
No, better not.
It's a distraction!
me it will work like that if you light the plants on fire and then they will run the people will run and there'll be a distraction haligan didn't find the previous conversation to be unpleasant the butler was way more polite to him than all of the colleagues
these aren't the plants that were in my boat room is it i oh
I'm much too far away There's an open window I see
I wish I had more salt Salt, salt We need more salt Snow, snow We need more snow Okay, I'm gonna throw fire on this guy Hello my friend, it's me again Hello.
Not in the right mood for office air yet.
Nah.
I'd like to ask you some things concerning our little conversation.
Of course.
Just ask.
I'll be finished here soon anyway.
Oh.
What are you doing at the moment?
I have to cut the hedges.
They grew rampantly this summer.
Lord Sinclair doesn't want to...
Oh, it's always... And his...
Okay, so this is all the same.
I have to go.
Duty calls.
Don't work too hard.
Thanks.
Have a good day.
Thank you.
Oh.
He saw what I was about to do.
I'd better not light that.
Wait.
What if I help him out?
Hey, buddy.
You need a little...
A snip in hand.
I'd rather not cut that.
You need a snip in hand?
I got you.
I can also cut the hedges.
Wait.
I'd rather not cut.
that.
You need some gloves?
That won't feel different with gloves either.
Okay.
This villa is really huge.
Such a palace for only one person.
Oh wait, what's this?
Do I set this on fire?
A lot of cut grass.
Oh, wait.
Wait.
What?
It's a disaster.
Oh, my God.
Oh, he's acting like a Sims.
For real.
Okay, let's take his scissors.
Nemi, thank you so much for the break.
Come back, everybody.
the sims was nimi able to i was able to watch for just only a little bit was nimi able to survive as a teenager oh thank you so much for the redirect this game is really nonsensical but it's very funny nimi actually i i recommend you play this i think you might like it
oh save oops damn the shears are broken i did commit arson I did wait save game we could always do that again if I have to set things on fire look how many saves I have everybody we could go in now go go go not touch it it could be electrified with my gloves Lord Sinclair is prepared nothing happens yeah then go inside nothing happens with the gloves the green scarf it's Janet's no I don't care maybe it is not a good idea no how do I get in then cut more oh I can cut more okay now these are broken scissors are broken as well but the hole should be big enough now okay let's go in stop wait a minute the fence is electrified oh the gloves here we go I don't know why this is called mystery of the druids and not the many crimes of Brent Halligan stop oh wait a minute go inside oh here we go i thought it wouldn't work like that okay now i can climb through here what if i touch the fence oh my god okay dangerous uh the scarf i'd rather think about it again no the fence that would be stupid
what do you mean that doesn't work you said it was big enough have you seen my scissors no the scarf it won't work like a scarf at the bottom i'd rather want that.
Think first, Brent.
No, better not.
He's yelling at me.
It won't work like that.
That won't get me.
It looks like that won't work.
I can't do that.
It's nonsensical.
No, better.
That won't help.
I thought it was.
There's no point in that.
That's futile as well.
Wait.
I don't believe it will work like that.
Think, Brent.
Think.
Brento.
Need to combine two nonsensical items.
it won't work like that now the bucket's hanging from the fishing rod I thought it wouldn't work like that okay uh hmm that doesn't work what what I created a pillow alrighty here we go
not any sense of urgency how do you do Mr. Halligan how nice of you to visit us you know my name Ricky Martin Certainly.
Lord Sinclair has been expecting you.
I'm the guest of honor?
Is that boss of yours some kind of psychic or what?
Why don't you ask him that yourself?
Let's go.
Da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da.
Uh-oh.
Is it because I committed arson or...
Okay, we gotta watch them walk inside.
Longest cuts in.
But we know that window was open, so we have an escape route.
I thought that's how I was getting in.
Mr. Halligan, it is a great pleasure to meet you in person at long last.
The pleasure's mine.
Would you mind telling your charming pet gorilla here to point a damn pistol somewhere else?
Thank you guys for all the don't know...
Give us this precautionary measure, Mr. Halligan.
I happen to be a distrustful man.
Lord Sinclair, now that we've met, there are a few questions I'd really like to ask you.
Certainly, certainly.
After dinner, I will answer any questions you tend to ask me.
Until then, please be my guest.
Jack, please be good enough to show our guest to his chamber.
You do not seem to be quite aware.
of the situation you are in, Lord Sinclair.
Well, no.
I think it's the opposite.
I don't want to have dinner with you.
I'm here because of a series of murders, but you are a prime suspect.
With all due respect, Mr. Halligan, I took you for a wiser man than that.
If anyone here is unaware of the situation they are in, you are.
Yes.
I have asked you to be my guest at dinner.
Please don't disappoint me by refusing.
I will have to ask Jack here to persuade you to stay in his own way.
I understand.
I'm to stay here voluntarily.
Because if I don't, you'll force me.
Is that it?
I'm glad we've settled that.
He's so old, but his skin is so smooth that the thing...
I...
We will discuss everything else in detail later over dinner.
Okay.
Let's go.
Ooh.
thank you very much oh he locked the door he locked me in wait did he keep the key in there okay
interesting brilliant absolutely brilliant locked up in lord sinclair's house
yep here we are here we are here we are me too i'm just gonna keep making saves too lazy We got some fruit?
Maybe poisoned.
The handles are locked.
Lord Sinclair thinks of everything.
This seems to be the way to the forest behind the house.
I see.
This seems to be the way to the forest.
Okay.
What's in here?
Firmly locked.
A wardrobe.
What's this?
These pictures are ugly.
What are...
These look fine to me.
These pictures are ugly.
This is the ugly thing.
Oh, my God.
We triggered a cutscene somehow.
Night has arrived.
That's all I needed.
The picture looks even weirder in the dark.
I took it.
Yoink.
We just stuffed that in our pockets.
You think dinner's ready?
Do we know how to turn on the light?
Typical of guest rooms.
These pictures are ugly.
The music's spooky.
We just took it.
Okay.
That's the picture with a tasteful motif.
Can't do anything without the key.
This door looks really solid.
Okay, we know.
We can use the fishing.
That would be stupid.
No, it would not because you need to get the key.
What if I slide it under?
Hmm.
Nothing's happening.
Okay.
I can feel that something's going on out there.
Screwed on.
Wait, can I like...
Dang it.
What about with this?
I know that it's like bent, but if it's just...
If they're just screws, you could probably...
I had the right idea of sliding.
I did.
Let's try it maybe.
Can't do anything, but not a good idea.
Okay, maybe not that, obviously, but...
What else do we have?
Fingerprint stuff.
It won't work like that.
No.
This stuff.
Hmm.
That doesn't work.
The bone.
That would be stupid.
Okay.
Get closer.
Can't do anything without the key.
Oh, there we go.
I didn't realize it was...
Okay, okay.
Oh!
Salt?
No way.
Oh, here we go.
Ah, here we go, here we go.
It won't improve if I put this picture next to it.
What is that?
What is the salt for?
Yeah, that stuff is explosive.
We gotta be careful.
That won't feel different with gloves, either.
Um...
You could hurt yourself with those.
There's no point in that.
Okay, I'm trying to think of what, maybe fingerprints.
That won't get me any further.
I mean, I can't do anything with this here.
Uh, hmm.
The paper.
It won't work like that.
I mean, we can only...
That is no important evidence, I'm sure, about that.
We can only use what we got, so it's got to be the case file again.
it out of the frame i don't believe lauri's paper scissors have suffered a bit part of the blade is gone sorry i'd rather think about it again uh i am missing an item wait what am i missing is it still locked firmly locked a wardrobe okay what am i missing an item nothing in the bed
Nothing on the table that I can grab.
Can I...
I wish I could see.
I can't see anything.
The keyhole is dark.
Wouldn't it make sense to push something through the keyhole then, huh?
I feel.
We use the painting to remove the nail on the wall.
Oh, wait.
can look at it.
This?
That's a nail.
That is a nail.
Oh my god.
What?
The painting?
Oh.
Wow.
Can't do anything without the key.
Oh my god.
Wait.
No, I would only scratch everything.
So it's not sticking the nail through underneath.
Okay, wait.
What can I combine this with the bone?
That won't help either.
I was going to say, like, to stick up under there and knock it down, but...
I should think about it.
Hmm.
Nothing's happening.
Wait, keep trying this?
No, I would... No, no, no, I would only scratch everything.
Oh!
Oh, there it is!
Okay, okay.
No, not a chance.
Uh...
That's the canvas I detached from the picture.
This is the frame of the picture I took down.
I can't see any connection there.
Okay, hold on.
We're brain plastic somehow?
No, no, no, no!
Um, okay, so we took this out.
I don't believe it will work like that.
I'd rather think about it again.
That would be stupid.
This puzzle is the worst one.
Please trust to use the nail on the floor.
I... I... I...
What the?
Why is he letting me do it now and didn't let me do it two seconds ago?
Oh, that sound is terrible.
Oh, I hate that.
Wait, why now?
What?
What was that?
God, somebody's screaming out there in the forest.
It's a specific pixel.
Oh my god, no way.
What the hell's going on out there?
I have to get out of here.
We have witness dinner ready.
Okay.
Now, what, do we scoop this or...
Uh, did we bucket it?
It won't work like that.
Okay.
What was the point of...
Wait, oh, now I can use the nail to not...
No, I would only scratch everything.
I'm just saying you don't scratch anything anymore.
Okay, so we undid this for some reason.
Uh-huh.
No, I would only scratch everything.
Of course.
It can't work like that.
Okay.
There's a slit under the door.
Uh-huh.
Now do I like...
hmm that doesn't work okay so I pushed I'm trying to see how it could push the key I think there's something in it on the other side maybe this they would have surprised me if it had worked like that push it I should think about it again can we turn on the light I wish huh
this is so nonsensical you were right with the nail okay okay so i was right okay i just can't see it because it's teeny tiny and so dark oh wait oh i did it i did it i got it i got it okay thank you yeah you can please let me know if i'm right and like i'm just missing where it is you know oh right on his face Okay,
before I use this, I'm going to save again.
We're on to Minto 10, everybody.
Oh, a key.
I guess that makes sense.
I guess maybe the slit under the door was not big enough for his hand to go through or something, so.
There we go.
It's locked.
What about here?
Oh, yeah.
Okay.
It's locked.
Everything is locked.
A door.
No idea where it leads to.
It's locked.
Mito's always a 10.
Ah!
It's locked.
Okay.
Are we going downstairs then?
Let's go, baby.
Where can I go?
Can we go?
It seems we can check this door.
Oh, we don't even need to check the door.
Oh, okay, here we go.
So can we go...
We can go this way.
We can go...
This is probably locked.
It's locked.
I have to find the back door.
A door?
This is the one we just checked.
Oh, wait, what's over here?
Look at this Resident Evil mansion.
Oh, this is Resident Evil based.
it's locked it's locked okay that one we can't check um let's check this i think i checked with my eyes before but i will check with my hands it's locked it's locked he seems a little more perplexed about that one being locked welcome to membership thank you
uh oh
the fire's already burning lord sinclair's guests must be arriving soon and he's preparing The food!
The food!
A weird picture.
Is it supposed to be a storm?
What do I need to remember how many trees there are or something?
Poop.
Earth and a shovel.
Hmm.
Oh wow, this one's nice.
An old castle by the sea.
Wow, wow, this is nice.
A torrential river.
sure the dinner table is laid for a dinner for six people yes anything I can take here the dinner table is laid for a dinner for six people six people okay oh there's more to observe over here this looks important that seems to be a pictogram but I don't know what it's supposed to mean River and campfire.
Hang on.
Haven't I seen this symbol before?
It's the same as the one on the amulet of the Lord of the Castle.
It was!
Look at that guy.
Wait, look at this tiny little guy!
Aw.
Uh-oh.
Wait, there's more.
Grab the silverware.
What's that?
Seems to be a pictogram, but I don't know what it's supposed to mean.
Not the rhino.
It seems to be a pictogram, but I don't know what it's supposed to mean.
Interesting, interesting.
Can I?
Oh, wait.
The dinner table is laid for a dinner for six people.
For six?
How many people do you think are going to be at this dinner?
Uh-oh.
Hey, what the?
Yay!
Yeah!
Oh, my God.
Shut up.
He keeps going.
no way the plating the plating though well Mr. Halligan I don't believe I have introduced you to the gentleman of my club yet this is General Myers of the British Army next to him is Bishop Stevenson wow the Earl of Sutcliffe one of the Queen's closest advisors the queen my mom the gentleman sitting beside you is mr smothers of the worldwide foods corporation oh and hear me I'm sure you're curious to learn what our club is all about what is going on I would suggest you have a bite to eat first you look pale what is happening you see mr.
Halligan you must know we have following your investigations into these shall we say deaths in London for some time I expect your experience in the park will have convinced you that we are to a certain degree responsible for these incidents we're just chowing down notice the meat we are eating at this meal has a rather unique flavor it is It doesn't care.
Keeps on chewing.
This flesh is the source of life force.
It grants us strength and power.
You will soon discover the incomparable feeling of power for yourself.
Wait, what?
It will be grander than any feeling you have ever felt.
Very soon now.
The day of the ritual's completion has come, our power will be...
Then it will be time for the curse That will put an end to the wretched hustle and bustle of this world And make rules for something grand and new A world ruled by druids World ruled by druids I must admit your investigations had us worried for a moment Mr. Halligan We had even made plans to put a stop to them By arranging a little Actually Once you are a very lucky man When you fry it real quick It's a great day yourself.
And you will be there on the right side.
My man has only had pits all his life.
Welcome to the circle, Mr. Halligan.
What?
Were we brainwashed?
What happened?
The key...
Right there?
My goodness, music.
Gosh, her eyelashes.
What's the routine, sis?
Welcome to the Patriots, Helgen!
No!
You let Clementine eat human meat.
Me and Wild.
Why is...
Why are the games I'm playing recently have so much human meat consumption lately?
What's...
For zombies?
The zombie the cannibalism pipeline, maybe.
Um, is that still on fire over here?
Wait, are we playing as a babe now?
They didn't kill him, did they?
No.
Cannibalism is in this season.
They just...
Wait, they just left...
Wait, they just left it.
you how like it how like it was just subsequently banned from the pizza players we're asking if they have human meat topics hello
yes hello is this lord sinclair no miss i am sorry i am lord sinclair's butler i'd like to talk to lord sinclair on what matter miss i'm looking for a detective from scotland looking for a detective miss in that case i would recommend you to contact scotland yard this is the house of lord sinclair which is not the circle's going to regret i thought the detective might be here no i am sorry a detective haligan has not been here could i talk to lord maybe he's secretly a genius i am sorry miss but he's pretending to be brainwashed i see have a good day all of their see all of their wrongdoings and collect all the evidence He's wearing meta glasses and is filming it all.
And then he'll present the evidence.
To...
Just pretending to be a cannibal.
Wouldn't you?
For the sake of the world!
There we go.
oh she's sneaking mission how there are some stones here oh some stones here my I should put them in my pocket oh my gosh no stinking way
stop stop right there wait how did you find me leave me alone you bastards well well there's no need to be that upset what are you doing here sweetheart are you looking for something i um i she got through the hole in the fence oh oh oh little lady little lady now lord sinclair will have a surprise guest for his dinner tonight what what are you going to do to me you'll find out soon enough sweetheart oh
so do i reload
I kind of want to see what happens though.
What are you doing here?
I'm preparing dinner.
You're having dinner with Lord Sinclair.
That bastard got me locked in here.
I want to see what happens though.
I really don't want to have dinner with someone like that.
You're not being asked.
What?
Mr. Halligan?
Is everything all right with you?
Come with me, Miss Turner.
Where?
Into the garden.
I have to prepare dinner.
In the garden?
Mr. Halligan, what are you talking about?
What's wrong with you?
With me, Miss Turner, dinner will be ready soon.
Oh, my God.
And you will be our guest of honor.
The skeletonized body of Dr. Melanie Turner was found in a forest near London only a few days after this conversation.
Detective Brent Halligan has been listed as missing.
He was last seen leaving his Scotland Yard department.
Game!
Over!
Okay, so I'm guessing I have to, like, distract them with the rocks.
Okay, hold on.
Oh, geez.
Wait, okay.
Load game.
Minto 11.
Okay.
All right.
Text is so anticlimactic.
Okay.
So funny.
I love it.
how there are some stones here stop stop right there no no
leave me alone well there's no need to watch I have to go through the whole sequence again please so she's just standing there I have to go... It won't let me go into the menu.
I have to go through the whole thing.
Oh, my gosh.
Okay.
Just to push.
How did they know?
Okay.
Hey, um...
It's so funny.
Chill Sloth.
Welcome back.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Uh, okay.
All right.
Here we go.
Load.
thank goodness you guys told me to save holy moly in fact i'm gonna save right in front of the bush so we or i can save right in here we'll save in here right okay ow there are some stones here all right save that's me too 12 resume okay now do i throw the stones at this guy.
I can throw them at the other bush.
Oh, wait.
What did that do?
Oh?
Oh, my goodness.
Thank you guys for the donuts.
I go!
Every time it's made been skeletonized.
Remains were found in her computer chair after watching this ending 400 times.
Thank you so much for the gifted.
It did nothing, yeah.
And I can't throw it at him.
I can throw it at him.
Throw it at one of the windows.
No.
I still can't throw it at him.
I don't want to just waste them, you know what I mean?
Like, since we have to go through such a castle too.
So I don't want to just try again with throwing it.
Is it like a pixel perfect?
No?
Well.
Maybe I was like too low on the body.
You know.
Lure them to the other bush.
It doesn't do anything.
Unless I have to wait for him to like come by.
Like.
Now.
Stop right there.
Hey.
Okay.
What is that?
Leave me alone, you bastards.
Oh, man.
What are you?
Stop.
You are violated the law.
That's how I feel about when I hear this.
Ah.
.
Don't you need to sneak to the other bush?
I might have to, but I tried that before and he still saw me, though.
Let me out of here.
Oh, there we go.
Okay.
Load game.
Run.
Stop.
Stop right there.
Maybe it's...
There was not great.
Okay.
I'll take the help.
Use the rock in the left bush in front when they're both facing their backs.
Bush on the left.
Okay.
Okay, I think.
Bush on the left.
Wait, huh?
Wait.
This?
Wait, this?
This bush right here?
Or is this hitting him?
I can't tell.
Yes.
Okay, hold on.
Okay, he does kind of keep his back turned for quite a bit, so.
All right, sorry.
I should have done it when...
But I was waiting for what his timing was.
All right.
What was that?
Let's have a look.
No rush.
Literal no sense of an urgency.
We're fine.
Stop.
Right there!
What did I do?!
Hey!
Leave me alone!
What happened?!
Was she too- I don't understand what the issue was!
If you don't wait behind the second bush, they get you anyway.
Is that really what it was?
Because I went- I clicked on the second bush first, and then I saw that there was like the way to- I have to do it twice.
Sorry.
Wait.
Oh, oops.
I was trying to...
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh my gosh!
What was that?
Let's have a look.
Okay.
So hide in the second bush first.
So now do I throw it again?
Nothing to be seen.
Oh my gosh, the game is not paused.
Stop right there.
Hey, what is that?
Leave me alone.
Okay, so you have to stop in the bush and then go.
Oh my god.
Dark Souls Appointing, good game.
Go to the second bush, and then once you are there at that bush, you go to the window.
Okay, that's...
Okay, okay, okay.
We'll get it this time, folks.
We'll get it this time.
Oh, my gosh.
Okay, load.
This.
Get the rocks.
And throw.
What was that?
Let's have a look.
I'm, like, traumatized by the...
voices now
run please run run please oh my god please run please run Melanie nothing to be seen yeah must have been a bird or something okay please go inside where am I now this is like being in a ghost train
a ghost tray looks expensive and weird somehow is it the skull Sinclair uses it as a paperweight is it the skulls on the chair is it the skull how can I take this heavy thing with me you could knock somebody out with that whoa yeah we should is it the skulls literally is it the sacrifice is it the bull blood behind his office that's weird is it literally the entire thing oh my gosh so funny is it this that looks like blood what's that an altar oh wow it's all the symbols again too uh-oh they have one pool of blood a pentagram a druid's foot would suit lord sinclair better what wait it's lined up oh what the hell what the hell what is this puzzle
god forbid a man has hobbies this looks like our anthropologist Apology office.
I guess that's true.
You're making them dance.
They're like stabbing him and then we stab the next.
Oh, wait.
I did something.
I think.
I heard it.
Did you guys hear it?
Something happened.
Oh!
Okay.
Oh, I'm a genius?
Yahoo!
Whoa!
Oh,
okay.
Oh, dang it.
I didn't mean to press it again.
I'll put some rocks on it.
Dang it.
She says the same thing.
Well, this rub is so freaky.
Are these skulls real?
Looks like it.
I think so.
Oh, gosh.
Okay.
Oh, what's in here?
bone soup bones these are definitely human bones nope okay bone soup anything else okay so how do I don't know what this is for we could take this and put it in how can I take this heavy thing with me you could knock somebody out with that and then
just show the symbols again.
Maybe we need to remember.
Up River, Campfire, Three, Sideways River.
Up River, Campfire, Sideways River, Three.
His desk looks expensive and weird somehow.
What did this solve, though?
Not quite sure.
Can it only go one way?
You're absurd.
After Zanzibar, Turner's skeletonized body was found.
Air, fire, earth, water.
Oh, you're right, maybe.
Brute force?
You want this?
Is it a safe code?
Yeah.
Oh, I can!
Okay.
Wait.
Sometimes it...
Sometimes it goes other way and sometimes it goes, you know?
So wait, is this the one first?
Code is 1016.
Thank you!
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine, ten.
How do I...
Sometimes I don't know how...
Okay, so 10.
Wait, or is this 10?
Because it does a little click.
So does this count as one...
Wait, this one?
No.
Okay.
Oh, it's like a clock.
One, two, three, four, five, six.
But it's not really.
Okay.
Dang it!
Oh, it is a clock.
Oh, I'm still counting wrong.
Hehehe.
Okay.
Voila!
This is the amulet of transformation Mr. Blake talked about.
It seems to be really important for Lord Sinclair.
Yeah!
And the thing.
What is this?
The parchment is full of runes.
I can't read a single word.
Well, maybe Mr. Blake can read it.
What's happening?
Ah!
No!
Mr. Halligan, God, what a relief.
Oh, what was that?
Why are you hitting me?
Who are you?
What are you doing here?
Oh, my God, stop it!
What's the matter with you?
Don't you recognize me?
Oh, my God!
Oh my god!
He just keeps slapping her!
Get it!
Use the skull to knock him out!
Yeah.
Rand, you bloody idiot.
Oh, maybe he's back to normal.
You think she wants to go see a movie with us?
What happened?
Brent, is that you?
Stop yelling!
You recognize me?
Stop yelling, please.
Of course I recognize you.
Bloody hell, what's going on?
Oh my god, I'm feeling sick.
Everything's spinning.
It's all the human meat.
I had to hit you over the head.
You were acting like a madman.
Wait, I just have to get it together for a moment.
Oh, Melanie, you can't imagine what I've gone through here.
Wait, can I?
Okay, I won't let me save.
Well, yeah.
How did you get here anyway?
Have you been here long?
I got your message.
Can't you remember?
I thought you might need help out here.
Oh, right.
The copy.
I had a look around the room, Brent.
It's a little frozen.
I found the amulet Mr. Blake mentioned on the phone.
It was in Sinclair's safe.
Together with a parchment.
So Sinclair had it.
I'm sure Mr. Blake will be interested in that.
But now, tell me what's been happening here, Brent.
What's Sinclair up to?
They've ruined my pizza only diet.
Oh, wait, what happened?
Wait, what?
What do you mean what happened?
What happened?
You threatened me.
You tried to kill me.
You're not you and you're hungry.
You tried to kill me, Brent.
You hit me.
Three times.
Don't ever do that again.
Do you understand?
Melanie, I didn't know what I was doing.
I can't even remember hitting you.
Oh, God, Brent.
It was a triple slap.
What's this Sinclair done to you?
It wasn't even like a punch.
Like, any sort of like, he didn't even like shove her.
It was just like, like so funny Melanie I saw how this Lord Sinclair killed somebody what when did you see that and where last night here on the estate Sinclair caught me immediately after my arrival and had me locked up I could hear screams when I was in that room horrible screams yeah I escaped and ran outside to the forest behind the estate yeah there I saw it what did you see Sinclair and some other men.
They wore habits.
Habits.
And they were just about to cut a living human being into pieces.
Yes.
With a sickle.
They had already done that.
That can't be true.
I saw it with my own eyes, Melanie.
It was horrible.
Oh, God.
And what happened to you?
Why didn't you recognize me?
Must have had something to do with the food.
So, you know, they...
Wait, wait, you didn't have to eat it.
It must have had something to do with the food.
What food?
Sinclair and his friends invited me to their dinner.
The food did something to me.
He was like, made me lose the job.
Anyway, Sinclair had no compunction in telling me all about the circle and about their future plans over dinner.
Wait.
The circle wants to complete the ritual.
You remember that.
And to put a curse on the world which will make us all their slaves.
Wait.
That's nonsense.
No, Melanie.
you've seen what these people did to me they're mad and they are serious i'm sure about that what's going on in there open the door open it at once the guards brent they're at the door we have to leave open the door jack get the key yeah melanie i think you're right we really should get out of here and we should do it now we made it oh yes thank god i couldn't have taken it in that house even a second longer everything all right with you yes i'm a bit out of breath and you okay get away from the house from that i'm okay we have to go melon yeah like keep going to mr blake if anybody can tell us something about the incidents in this house he can okay let's move mr blake i'm glad you're here there's a lot we need to tell you we've experienced something simply incredible calm down mr halogen let's discuss it all in peace and quiet perhaps you'd like to introduce me to the young lady oh oh of course i almost forgot in Mr. Blake,
this is Dr. Melanie Turner from the Anthropological Museum in Oxford.
Oh yes, of course.
We spoke on the telephone.
That's right.
Nice to meet you at long last, Mr. Blake.
Now, what's been happening?
Have you found out any more about the circle?
Any more?
It's a nightmare, Mr. Blake.
Go on.
Okay, I want to save so badly, but...
Mr. Blake, we found the amulet you were talking about.
The amulet of transformation.
You found it.
my god show me he just gave it to you that's it where was it in a hidden safe in the office of the leader of this ominous circle there was a parchment with it with completely illegible signs on it here take a look he
can read it do they make any sense to you hmm very unusual runes you can't read it take a look at this in peace go on with your story you were saying you know who's leading the circle who is it the circle is led by an aristocrat named Lord Sinclair the circle is led by an aristocrat called Lord Sinclair aristocrat Lord Sinclair never heard of him how did you find out research Scotland Yard observed the group for a while there was an entry in the database so I drove out to his place it's a pretty pretentious estate on Winchester Street you drove out there all by yourself yeah that was rather careless of you mr.
Halligan you can say that again he'd obviously been expecting me and had me locked up at once yeah what happened next I witnessed a murder actually guys give me one second I'm gonna go grab some more water I was waiting for a chance to like save I could grab it but give me one second I'll be right back Oh,
dokey, dokey, dokey, dokey, dokey, dokey, dokey, dokey, dokey, dokey, so much more.
Oh, dust, different darts.
I've got to take a cough drop or a throat drop.
A throat drop.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, I saw a murder.
I witnessed a murder taking place.
Murder?
On Sinclair's estate?
Yes.
I saw them cutting the flesh from a human body.
Look at that.
Thank you.
body with a sickle yes i knew it what you witnessed was a ritual for the transferal of life force were you seen i passed out when i came to i was sitting at a laid table with sinclair and four other men was there food on the table yes meat you didn't eat any surely yes i did i suppose i know it was the victim's flesh wasn't it yes i did you have taken part in the ritual mr How on earth did you manage to get away?
Ms. Turner got me out.
If it hadn't been for her, I wouldn't be here now.
You're a brave woman, Ms. Turner.
Yeah, she's awesome.
What do we do now?
Why don't we just send a police contingent round there?
You're a detective, Mr. Halligan, and Lord Sinclair is a murderer.
There won't be anything to find by the time they get there.
Sinclair and his friends are no fools.
They'll proceed as they've done in all the other cases.
They'll just dump the bones somewhere to save the police hunting high and low for a Scutland Yard will file it away.
End of case.
That's all for now.
Wait, wait, wait, wait!
But I saw them commit murder!
But I saw them commit murder.
Yes, you're a witness.
A simple detective up against five highly influential citizens.
Who'd believe you?
You don't stand a chance.
The way we're all just standing here.
Okay.
How can we stop these people?
I'm afraid we won't be able to.
Lord Sinclair and his friends are untouchable.
And every one of their rituals makes them more powerful.
You don't even know him.
Have you found out yet what stopped the completion of the ritual 1,000 years ago?
I've deciphered the text a little further, but some of the signs are just completely unknown to me.
I thought you said the amulet was important to the ritual.
Yeah.
Yes, that's what the inscription says.
But then everything's all right now.
After all, I've got it.
then this nightmare will be over.
Mr. Halligan, you're forgetting the ritual has already taken place.
1,000 years ago, it just didn't reach perfection.
Only part of the power was transferred to the infants.
The inheritors are now trying to complete their ritual.
But if this amulet means so much to Sinclair, surely it must be needed for the perfection.
I'm not so sure about that.
Sinclair may be interested in it for some other reason.
What makes you think that?
The title written on the parchment you gave me.
What does it say?
What does the parchment's title say?
Unless I'm very much mistaken, the text refers to a place known as Twelve Bridges.
What kind of place is that?
Twelve Bridges is an abandoned complex near Glastonbury.
The bridges are in great danger of collapsing.
Ancient Celtic myths refer to the place as the Gate of the Worlds.
Gate of the Worlds?
Yeah, we could still melt it down just to be sure.
You know, Mr. Heligan, the Celts did not regard reality and time insurmountable facts.
On the contrary, they regarded them as illusions, which man's laziness and ignorance made him incapable of overcoming.
Celtic shrines were always special places that allowed them to leave the normality of everyday reality.
Celtic myths claim that 12 bridges has been a consecrated site for millennia, a place where the body can step over into another time.
Uh oh, this is getting kind of wackadoo.
Can you read what the parchment says?
The signs resemble those on the inscription I'm working on.
But I'm just not getting anywhere with it.
All I've been able to make out of the parchment so far is the title.
I need a special book to continue.
The Celtic Orthographic System by Scott M.
Winfield.
Oxford University Library should have it.
Okay.
Mr. Halligan, please get me a copy of that book.
We can do that.
I believe the translation of this parchment is the key to Lord Sinclair's intentions.
Perfect, we'll go do that.
But nothing's ever been reported of such a journey.
Nothing's ever been reported of such a journey.
Well, that doesn't make it impossible, does it?
The place has not been closely examined so far.
It's too dilapidated.
She has no thoughts.
Entering the place is taking a very serious risk.
Anyway, nobody really believes in time travel anymore these days.
Nah, nobody believes in time travel anymore.
Geez!
Wait, this might be, if there's time travel, this might become my favorite game ever.
Why do they call the place 12 bridges?
It's a very strange arrangement of 12 stone bridges.
No one knows why they were built that way.
They probably weren't the first thing that was erected there anyway.
The current bridge array dates from the early Middle Ages.
If, as I suspect, that place has been a Celtic shrine for centuries, there are bound to have been other structures there at some point.
Why would Sinclair keep a parchment about that place?
She hasn't blinked.
She hasn't done anything.
Mr. Halligan, that's what I've been wondering.
If Sinclair knows the place and keeps a parchment about it hidden in his safe, wouldn't it be conceivable that journeys through time really are possible from 12 bridges?
You mean he wants to travel back in time?
Well, he'd certainly be doing his best to make sure nobody else made that journey.
Maybe Sinclair wants to prevent anyone from traveling back in time and disturbing the ritual.
Why would anyone do that?
And why would Sinclair be so concerned about it?
It's easy.
No ritual.
No inheritors.
No Lord Sinclair.
I see.
Yeah.
Of course, these are just speculations.
As I said, Mr. Halligan, we need the book from the library.
I should be able to tell you more when I've translated the parchment.
Thank you, Mr. Blake.
I'll see what I can make of it.
Good.
We have to go take care of Melanie now.
If you have any more questions, don't hesitate to call on me.
Anytime you like.
okay oh she's fine are you okay okay all these are for the books all right let's keep going
oh this thing is getting more and more mysterious i can't believe what mr blake said i need to find out why this amulet is so important to sinclair perhaps mr blake is right the amulet is the key to preventing the ritual i expect we'll know more as soon as the finished i have to go to oxford melanie i have to get the book for mr come with me yes of course that's fine by me i really need to check a few things at home where shall we meet later i'll get in touch with you as soon as i have any news okay all right i'll be off then okay melanie see you later i don't think it's good to split up i don't think that's a good idea all right what are we at mental 14 maybe okay oh we saved oh we don't have to go through all that i will ever again.
Awesome.
Love it.
Never be skeletonized again.
Oxford Library.
Whoa.
A sculpture of a unicorn.
Not quite to my taste.
Nobody asked.
What's over there?
This is it.
Oxford University Library.
only one bike seems the vacation has started let's go in
so many birds wait whose car is this oh it's an alarm car it's protected it's a bmw definitely a bmw yeah i knew that even it's locked why are we trying to bust into this guy's car what's wait what is this why are we doing this how can halogen call her if he's broke maybe we made some money working for Mr. Sinclair mid game sponsorship can you imagine going to the car company and being like okay guys we have this sick plan for a game
it's a magnetic barrier they have them in all libraries yeah they do we will we will just kidding okay Oh, what's this?
Snail!
An old book.
It's bound to be valuable.
I'm pretty sure this isn't the book, Blake meant.
Okay.
Wait, is the one that he did mean?
Is it going to be in this glass?
Oh, gosh.
I'm pretty sure this isn't the book, Blake meant.
An old illustrated book.
Let's go ask the desk.
Oh, my gosh.
Thank you for another 20!
Engineer, thank you.
Thank you so much.
Hello, hello, hello.
Excuse me, I'm looking for a book.
Oh, how nice for you.
Quite.
Do you think you could help me?
Help you?
Why?
Oh.
Uh, why?
Why?
As I said, I'm looking for a book.
I heard what you said.
You're looking for a book.
Yeah?
So, go ahead and look.
Aren't you not the librarian?
The music's so nice here.
Yeah, isn't it your job?
Librarian to help me?
I thought it was your job to give people like me information.
Don't think you can tell me what my job is.
It was an obvious question.
Look, young man, my job is to answer questions the computer can't answer.
Have you asked the computer yet?
Actually, I'm no...
No.
Well, then, go to the computer and check the database.
Hmm.
I'll see what I can do by myself, then.
You do that.
Everybody's so mean here.
Okay.
We BGM to Animal Crossing Museum, BGM.
What's this book?
Oh my gosh, there's so many areas to visit in here.
An old book written with a quill pen.
I'm reasonably sure this isn't the book.
Okay, what about this one?
Somehow I don't think this is the book Blake was talking about.
It's so cute though.
I'm pretty sure this is an old book.
I like these statues of like these super skinny women.
Okay.
Oh, Mr. I need the computer right now.
Excuse me, sir.
I hope I'm not disturbing you.
Hmm.
You know whose car that is outside?
Do you know whose car that is outside?
Out in the forecourt?
That's my car.
That's how we get him off the computer.
Oh my god.
We're going to get him off the computer by breaking into his car and making the car alarm go off.
I think a couple of students have damaged the paintwork.
Hmm.
Are you trying to get me to go out there so that you can perhaps get to the computer?
Not bad, young man, but I've been working here for 30 years now.
of youngsters trying to pull the wool over my eyes.
You'll have to come up with something better than that to fool me.
Oh, why don't you go, uh, don't say I didn't warn you.
Oh, well, it's up to you.
Don't say I didn't warn you.
Mm-hmm, uh-huh.
Whatever.
I'm staying right here.
Why don't you go sit for yourself?
Why don't you go out and see for yourself?
Don't talk nonsense, young man.
Our students wouldn't do that sort of thing.
It could be anybody.
to walk up.
I'm not a student.
I love that Minto is starting to think like Halligan.
Oh, well.
That's all right, then.
Okay.
Now what can I use?
A ladder for reaching the top rows.
What can I use to...
A table.
A stute observation, Halligan.
To make his car go off.
What's this?
Which one?
That one.
They don't seem to be sorted by author.
This one.
The one that's highlighted.
That one.
They don't seem to be sorted by author.
Which one?
A table.
Maybe there's another computer.
There's gotta be more than one computer, right?
Which one?
The book.
The book, the book.
the book.
What are these?
What is this?
Oh, okay.
It's mine.
That's the book.
The Roman monetary system and fiscal policies must be a best seller.
Why did we take it?
I don't understand this man at all.
Which one?
Really?
There's only one computer?
with a library of this size.
I know that we're like, what, in the 90s, but come on.
Which one?
Wolf.
This place is humongous.
Which one?
Which?
There must be thousands of books in here.
I know.
Crazy.
um over here all the way over here i'm just exploring at this point then i'll go back outside
okay nothing nothing here let's go okay this guy's car is so cooked
wait oh i was like what happened i thought he got on the ground for a second So I have this book.
Oh my god, there's people up here!
That does not look safe.
That looks extremely unsafe even.
I say stop right there.
What's the matter?
Don't you dare act the innocent.
You're trying to steal that book.
Who, me?
Steal a book?
Madam, I'm a detective.
They're always the worst.
Anyway, I can see it.
If you want to borrow a book, be good enough to come over to my desk.
Okay, this one.
Oh, um, this one?
There must be some mistake.
I was lost in thought, you see.
It must have slipped into my pocket.
This guy?
Just how often do you think I've heard that one?
He's such a pathological liar.
I'll put the book back and be grateful that I'm not having you thrown out.
Why is he such a...
Why is...
He's such a pathological liar.
He's such a freak.
Oh my gosh.
I don't want to borrow this book.
why not why did we take it you again haven't you found your book yet no how could I look I'd really appreciate your helping me yeah and he's so bad oh my god I
could be I'm gonna be a parent just go and have a word with your employer professor own if you like go ahead but I can give him a message for you if you prefer he's my husband oh nepotism nepotism your husband's a very lucky man i don't envy him your husband i must confess i don't envy him what what you're saying young man
i'll see what i can do by myself like you're such a catch halogen like wait it was in this room real yeah
This guy has so much nerve.
Wow.
Wait, I can't put...
Oh, yeah, I can't put it back.
No, better not.
Wait, what do you mean?
We have to put it back, no?
Wait, huh?
Do I, like...
I thought maybe throwing it over the alarm.
Let's see if that's what we need to do.
Oh, wait.
Oh, no.
Oh, nope.
Well, of all the...
Young man, if you're looking for trouble, you're going the right way about it.
Okay, calm down.
My mistake.
Lord, give me strength.
What a nerve.
Um...
You need help?
Try again.
Let's try one more time.
Well, of all the...
No.
Young man, if you're looking for trouble, you're going the right way about it.
Okay, calm down.
My mistake.
Lord, give me strength.
What a nerve.
Um...
Let's see.
Wait a second.
No.
Do you want the book, mister?
Do you want it?
Oh.
We're framing him for the crime Oh
my We're framing him We're really We're doing this Go
Brent Halligan Ruinner of all lives I can't believe this I can't believe this guy he's actually so insane um now i i thought maybe i would like throw the book in there or something and cause the alarm to go up but actually i'm not quite sure um no i would only scratch everything oh that's our big problem right now scotland yard's finest You need a key item that I don't have.
Oh, okay.
All right.
Is it here?
I need to go back all the way to the Sinclair's hedges.
And take a piece of wire!
I do!
I'm not gonna get killed going back here.
Why do I...
When was I supposed to pick up the wire?
I kind of get why that woman at the police station didn't want to go out with him.
Yeah.
Wait, how do I...
How do I grab it?
Bottom right.
Oh, wait.
Holy moly.
You guys, weeks of entertainment.
anyone beat this game?
How did anybody beat this?
Weeks!
Years even!
I can't do that.
Yes, you can.
Wait.
There we go.
Wee-woo, wee-woo, wee-woo.
What are we... Oh, my God.
Oh, thank goodness.
Oh, they have enough sense to Professor Hastings, what are you doing?
Who?
Me?
Nothing.
I must be off to my car.
My alarm just went off.
Professor, what's that book you're carrying?
Book?
I don't have a book.
Please don't joke now, Mrs. Owen.
I have to see to my car.
What's this then?
But how the devil... that's impossible.
I didn't take this book.
Then how did it get there?
There must be some mistake.
A very regrettable mistake.
I assure you...
I like your nerve, Professor Hastings.
You steal a book and then try to deny the whole thing ever happened.
I'm very disappointed in you.
Mrs. Owen, you've known me for 20 years now.
You ought to know that I've never...
All I know is that I'm going to have to put this on record.
Please come along over here to the Ishing counter, Professor.
You will have to fill in a form.
Oh my god, he's so sad.
destroying lives.
Where?
This is going on his permanent record!
Anyway.
If you did this without him holding the book, he would have caught you breaking into his car and Halligan gaslights him super hard.
Reload to save if you want to see.
Uh, no, it's okay.
That sounds crazy.
I should save, though.
I should save.
Save game.
Minto 6 2.
I Wow Oh, I guess if you never pick up the book Because I was like, how would you get rid of the book?
Anyway, um, computer's free There's no 15 Oh, oopsie That's okay My turn on the computer Beep, boop, boop Beep, boop, boop, boop, boop Beep, boop, boop 99 me there's one left right that baby is mine why do i have a feeling this book this library is gonna be caught on fire or something
whoa what library position 48 3 cb 48 3 cb okay everybody Help me out here.
48.
Oh, wait.
See?
Wait.
Wait, but where's 48?
Uh.
How do we know?
Wait, let's go back out.
Doesn't have...
Do you see it?
I don't see anything anywhere.
Two digits means second floor.
Wait, really?
I know this guy is stressing me out a little bit.
Can we go upstairs?
It's, unless it's not roped off anymore, we couldn't.
Yeah, see, we can't even go upstairs, you guys.
Maybe, what was the biggest room was this one, maybe?
There was ladders, right?
I don't think that's,
wait, here?
They don't seem to be sorted by author.
It's not, let's go to that one area, Okay, hold on.
There was one where that book was, like, suspiciously highlighted.
It could be that one.
Wait, bookshelf C, middle section.
Like, I know I was at C.
But am I at 48?
Is it, like, a pixel perfect something?
Oh, oh, now he uses the ladder.
Oh, my gosh, I tried to get him to use it before!
Ah, wow, that's a hefty book.
Oh, okay.
Slip into...
What a cool guy!
Oh, okay.
I guess I got it.
Interesting.
What the hell?
Ma'am, help me, please.
I would like to check out this book.
You again.
Haven't you found your book yet?
No.
Wait!
How could I?
Look, I'd really appreciate your helping me.
You repeat yourself, young man.
Huh?
Wait, no, no, oh, maybe I have to...
Oh, wait, okay, I have to...
I thought it was your job to give people like me information.
Don't think you can tell me what my job is.
It was an obvious question.
Look, young man, my job is to answer questions the computer can't answer.
Have you asked the computer yet?
Okay, hold on.
I tried to exit out.
Exit, okay.
Now I do this.
Okay, here we go.
Here, madam.
the book I was looking for there we go I'd like to borrow it this one yes please is there something wrong with it you bet there is this is our reference copy what's that supposed to mean I can't lend it to you you will have to read it here no you can't be serious surely I need this book I have to take it to someone you heard me if only we had like a cell phone we could just take pictures of it do you at least have a copying do you at least have a why don't you copy the pages you need by hand madam I've told you the books not for me I wouldn't know which pages are important and I can hardly copy the whole book by hand that's not your problem right right I thought as much oh my god couldn't you make an exception couldn't you make an exception we don't do exceptions have you any idea how many reference copies we have had stolen All right,
forget it.
What do I do?
Run for it.
Minto 17.
I like that movie.
Here we go.
Run.
Well, of all the...
Young man, if you're looking for trouble, you're going the right way about it.
Run!
Okay, calm down.
My mistake.
Lord, give me strength.
What a nerve.
Okay.
How do I copy all this down then?
Hmm.
Can I get one of the sad students to do it for me?
Wait, how do I...
How do I write all this down?
For real.
No, no.
Wait.
Hmm.
I think you steal it.
Oh, you're back.
It's your car, okay?
Hello, Professor.
Still busy.
I thought maybe you'd been thrown out by now.
Hmm?
Hang on.
Nearly finished.
It's pointless.
He's in a world of his own.
Let's see.
Okay.
Can we...
Hmm.
Right.
Wrap it up as evidence.
This is official.
I thought it wouldn't work like that.
Dang it.
This is official business.
That won't help either.
Uh, can we cut out the pages?
Looks like that won't work.
Okay.
Or this one.
No way.
Okay.
Maybe.
That won't get me any further.
No.
Hmm.
Use the book from before.
How would that help, though?
It was in this one.
I shall combine them and see.
Yoink.
I cannot yoink it.
Why did we try to take this anyway?
Swapping.
out the covers.
Well, I can't take it anyway, so...
What if I damage it?
With my drink.
That's futile as well.
There's no point in that.
Drag it into the pile.
Try.
Oh, so smart.
Use the frame to frame the profile.
Ah, that's how we disguise it.
history book is a perfect fit for the book I want to borrow wait but this one will also set off the alarm no what is the logic here how to swapping the cover don't the covers have the alarms on them
well off oh wait I can check it out if you're looking for trouble you're going the right way about it okay calm down I got it I got it!
I got it!
Were you guys yelling at me to say that you were like, no, we don't, don't go through the alarm!
This is not a reference copy!
No, no, no, no, no.
You've played two games with accidental cannibals.
One star is a vicious, dangerous criminal willing to break the rules to get his way, and the other star is Lee.
Right, I've finished here.
I found a different book that interests me.
I assume you'll let me borrow this one.
We'll see.
checking it out.
Solve this, the logic is stupid.
No, no, this one actually makes sense.
Oh, the Roman monetary system and fiscal policies.
Yes, you may borrow this one.
And just think, I've actually read this one.
What a coincidence.
It's because they have so many copies of this one.
Very vivid.
It's not a reference copy.
That's why swapping the covers is okay.
And Roman coins were my special field.
But then I met my husband here at the university.
He was working on his doctoral thesis know how it is i could quit yapping lady oh my gosh um madam this is all highly interesting but i do really want to borrow this book oh yes of course forgive me thank you thank you for the book and your great help oh i do hope you're not angry with me if there's any way i can help you please don't hesitate to tell me why is she suddenly flirting with me i really must be off now soon see you soon why is she flirting with me all of a sudden is it because i'm a i'm a well-read man
yay theft successful yipper yippie okay 18.
i wonder how many saves we'll get to
Okay.
Please run.
There we go.
Okay.
Oh, yeah, baby!
Now steal the car.
Okay, now let's go back to Mr. Blake.
He's alive, right?
He's still alive.
He's here.
He's alive and well.
Blake, open the door.
It's not going to be Ricky Martin.
Ask her to the cinema.
Okay.
Here you are.
Here's the book you asked for.
Ah, yes.
Don't mind the cover.
Thank you, Mr. Halligan.
You're welcome.
Well, did you have any difficulties with Mrs. Owen at the issuing counter?
None I couldn't handle.
Good.
I'll get to work at once.
Oh, by the way, Mr. Halligan.
Miss Turner called about an hour ago.
Miss Turner!
She's worried about you because you haven't been in touch for such a long time.
The way his arms.
Yes.
She said she needs to speak to you urgently.
Do you mind if I use your phone?
No need.
I asked her to come out here and join me.
She should be arriving any minute now.
Any minute now?
Oh my god!
Sorry, the music just...
How long will the translation take?
Oh, not long, I hope.
The book will be a great help.
You'd better just wait here for a moment.
I'll just take a look around then, if you don't mind.
Of course not.
Be my guest.
Be our guest, be our guest.
Oh!
That was so fast.
Mr. Halligan, there you are.
I've been looking everywhere for you.
I don't know if you've seen Amazing World of Gunball, but there's a scene where Darwin turned into a ghost as I can finally do this and kiss his carry.
Yeah, that's me.
What do you mean by that?
I'm touched at your concern.
Now, don't go imagining things.
that I should be worried about you and mr.
Blake she's really not into us at all and mr.
Blake well I had to get him well I had to get mr.
Blake this book that took rather a long time I've been phoning around asking for you you've been trying to get hold of me yes I also went to Scotland Yard and spoke to your chief he's a bit cross with you cross with me why what have I done now Lord Sinclair's planning to bring charges against you for burglary what I don't believe it that old devil Sinclair seems to feel he's pretty safe doesn't he he looks that way seems he has very influential friends in the police force whatever your chief asked me to tell you that you're suspended effective immediately oh and the next time you come to the office he expects you to give him a comprehensive report in writing what he can't be serious don't tell he's handing the case back to that thick-headed big-mouthed Lowry.
I wouldn't know.
All he said was that he expects you to hand the fire to him as soon as you get back to the yard.
I certainly will not.
This business is just too important to let go.
I don't care what the chief says.
I'm gonna carry this case through on my own.
Oh, what's happening?
A cutscene?
What's going on out there?
What's happening?
Oh.
What is it?
What's happening?
Oh my god, we almost got smushed by that clock.
Leave me, get out of the danger zone.
Here, take the parchment and go.
The danger zone?
Come along, Mr. Blake.
Let's get out of here.
You get out of here.
I'll follow you.
Wait, what's happening?
Get out of here.
Quickly, run!
What's the danger zone?
I believe you have to.
something of mine, Mr. Hannigan.
I shall give you until sunset to give my property back to me.
What just happened?
Why was the house shaking?
Was it a tank?
And now we're just standing here, staring at it.
Oh, God!
Mr. Blake!
I have to go back and get him out of there.
Are you crazy?
Don't it's pointless you can't help him anymore he's dead yeah you're right oh my god let's get out of here Melanie otherwise we'll be next where can we go to Scotland yard no that's not a good idea the chief inspector's waiting for me there we'd only lose time and Sinclair is getting more and more powerful with each new murder so what can we do you heard what mr.
Blake said Sinclair has the power to complete the ritual no matter what we do for the time being nobody can fireball no melanie we have one chance left what do you mean we have to go to 12 bridges we have to try to move the gate of the world's if we want to stop time travel we have to stop those who gave him his power a thousand years ago you believe in that gate of the world's thing it's just a myth a fairy tale we just saw a fireball blow up this guy's house the question is
come on then oh my god whoa what the hell is this structure what oh my this is this is just out here in the open oh my god two
thirds way through the game yippee yeah i was thinking probably calling it here but let's we're at caution danger oh my god
this place is just incredible yes it's beautiful but also rather ramshackle just like mr blake told us why is my game like this um okay let's have a look around There we go.
Wee!
Mr. Blake!
I called his death like five times.
I was like, this guy's gonna die!
He's gonna die!
Let's see.
12 doors.
Is that what it's called?
12 doors?
We'll just save it as that.
My goodness.
I did not give them the rights to use the likeness of my house.
Do you think my house would sell for a lot if I built one of these in the backyard?
I think honestly, everyone could.
The music is so whimsical.
Every British town has one of these?
A church, a Starbucks, and a giant chasm pit with a tower in the middle.
It's pretty cliche.
Oh, 12 gates.
Oops.
This is so beautiful.
Oh.
I didn't think anyone knew about this game.
Well, I'm playing it.
Oh, it's already been a crazy, crazy ride, but this has been so much fun.
I'm almost tempted.
Okay.
Can I beat this game instead of played Bloons this week?
Can I play?
I don't think I want to wait until when I get back.
I might edit my schedule.
I think I'll play this.
I think I'll beat this on Wednesday instead of playing Bloons.
We'll do that instead.
I don't want to wait until...
Because I would have to wait.
Then I'll be gone for a couple days and then...
I'd have to wait until after my birthday stuff.
And then I have a collab with...
Well, yeah.
So...
I want to just...
I just want to see what happens.
So we'll do that Instead of playing Bloons We will beat this game So exciting Yeah, Bloons can wait Bloons can wait Oh my gosh Collab Oh yeah, I have a collab with Doki It's been a while since she and I had just been Done a collab with She and I Bloons isn't going anywhere Yeah,
we gotta save the world This game has been a trip so far if you want to play similar but less insane game.
Broken Sword Shadow of the Templars.
But I love the insanity.
I've been laughing so much at this.
It's so great.
What?
It's my favorite point and click game of all time.
Thank you, Mindo.
Thank you!
Thank you guys for all the help as well with some of these crazy obtuse puzzles.
Some of them!
I sometimes get on my own, a little bit.
But, yeah, it's been so much fun.
And I can't wait to beat it and see what the conclusion is.
I'm so hyped.
We learned so much today.
Arson, vandalism, trespassing, forgery, theft, cannibalism.
We're the best of the best to ever do it at the Scotland Yard.
Takiso, thank you so much for the five good to thank you.
crazy too oh i will look into it hmm i suggested this and now i recommend limbo the law oh that's double limbo of the loss i'll write it down limbo of the loss i'll look into it first okay okay then everybody i thank you so much for joining me for more the mystery of the druids Can't wait to finish it later!
Have you ever heard of the game lunacy?
It's like this but even more scuffed.
I don't think so.
But yeah, it's Amido.
Have a good day, have a good night, have a good time zone, and I will see you when I see you ne- I'd rather not.
Thank you so much for the vibe.
Good day.
Thank you.
Ochami, doye, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye.
Bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye.
Bye-bye-bye.